[Musique]
bonsoir nous voici donc réunis pour ce
débat entre les deux participants au
deuxè tour de l'élection présidentielle
monsieur Valéri giscardestin et Monsieur
François mitteran ce débat a été
organisé par la commission de contrôle
avec l'accord des représentants des deux
candidats il sera dirigé par deux
journalistes choisi d'un commeun accord
Michel cotta journaliste à RTL et
moi-même Jean boisson
journaliste à l'expansion et chroniqueur
à europin nous devons veiller à
l'organisation à l'animation et au
déroulement de ce débat chaque candidat
disposera de 50 minutes pour répondre
aux questions que nous leur poseront et
qu'ils s'opposeront l'un à l'autre puis
il leur restera à chacun 5 minutes pour
conclure nous avons regroupé en trois
grands thèmes les questions qui peuvent
être posées le premier autour des
problèmes de politique intérieure le
deuxème sur les questions de vie
quotidienne des Français et de la vie
économique le 3isè sur les problèmes de
politique extérieure chacun de ces
thèmes sera se déroulera pendant 30
minutes puis pendant une dizaine de
minutes nous poserons des questions de
caractère plus général avant que chaque
candidat conclud en 5 minutes la
commission de contrôle a demandé à ce
que les personnes qui sont présentes
dans cette salle ne manifestent pas leur
sentiment pendant le déroulement du
débat aussi nous les remercions
d'aviance de bien vouloir taire ou leurs
enthousiasmes ou leurs réprobation
pendant la durée de la discussion
commençons donc par la politique
intérieure Michel cotta pose la première
question j'ajoute que le tirage au sort
a désigné Monsieur François Mitterant
pour parler le dernier pour conclure
cette émission et ce sera donc monsieur
Valéri giscardestin si vous le voulez
bien qui parle le premier alors Monsieur
valer giscardesttin monsieur mitteron au
fond à l'issue du deuxème tour vous avez
devant vous à peu près le même problème
vous avez obtenu l'un et l'autre le 26
avril plus de 25 % le quart du corps
électoral mais l'un et l'autre vous avez
besoin pour être élu d'un autre car vous
François milteran vous avez besoin des
communistes et vous valergis cardestin
vous avez besoin des électeur de Jacques
Chirac alors ma première question est
celle-ci votre stratégie de conquête à
l'égard des électeurs chiriens
n'est-elle pas trop rapide lorsque vous
dites Jacques Chirac a eu raison
parlez-vous seulement de sa lutte contre
la bureaucratie y a-t-il pour vous un
Jacques Chirac qui a eu raison et un
Jacques Chirac qui continuerait d'avoir
tort mademoiselle tirage au sort fait
que je réponds le premier bonsoir
François mitteran je veux dire dans quel
esprit je suis venu participer à ce
débat je crois je souhaite d'abord que
ce débat soit
utile les Françaises et les Français ont
un choix important faire c'est un choix
important en raison de la situation
internationale en raison aussi de des
alliances politiques de l'un ou de
l'autre qui font que la société
française en tout cas la politique de la
France s'engagera dans des directions
différentes voire même opposé suivant
que vous-même monsieur miterant ou moi
seront élus dimanche prochain j'ai lu ou
entendu que ce soir on dirait s'il y a
un vainqueur ou un vaincu je ne suis pas
venu pour cela c'est dimanche prochain
que les Français éclairé dirons qui doit
être président de la République j'ai
pendant 7 ans eu des dialogues de ce
type avec un certain nombre de
dirigeants du monde je sais ce qu'en
sont les règles il n'y a pas d'agression
personnelle c'est tout à fait inutile on
ne consacre pas de long développement au
passé il est derrière nous on regarde ce
que l'on doit faire et ce que l'on
propose et c'est ce que je compte faire
avec vous ce
soir alors la question de de Michel
Cotar je dirais d'abord C pas que
l'intérêt de ce débat ce soit la
politique du second tour franchement je
ne suis pas venu pour cela je ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'enjeu pour la France
que Monsieur min en ferait ce que je
ferais Moi-me d' question en fait depuis
7 ans j'ai pu gouverner enfin gouverner
agir comme président de la République
avec un gouvernement sans crise et sans
dissolution avec une majorité qui était
composé de deux tendances principales le
RPR et l'UDF elles se sont à certain
moment bien entendu au moment des
élections de 78 elles ont eu d'autres
moments des affrontements au total il n
a jamais de motion de censure votée et
il n'y a jamais de crise politique je
n'aperçois aucune raison pour que cette
situation soit modifiée après l'élection
présidentielle j'observe d'ailleurs que
la totalité des dirigeants du RPR quasi
totalité des élus de cette formation
veulent bien soutenir à l'heure actuelle
ma candidature à la présidence de la
République et comme j'ai indiqué
moi-même qu'il n'y aurait pas de
dissolution il n'y a donc pas de
problème politique à cet égard il y aura
tout de suite la reprise de l'action
gouvernementale et parlementaire quand
j'ai dit que jacquesac avait eu raison
de mettre l'accent sur un certain nombre
de problèmes qu'est-ce que j'ai voulu
dire dès le début de cette campagne j'ai
dit que j'écouterai ce qui sera dit dans
cette campagne il y a des choses à
apprendre et une campagne révèle
toujours un certain état d'esprit de la
population les préoccupations de liberté
économique de déburaucratisation de la
société française d'allègement de
certaines charges ont été exprimé
notamment par jacac et j'ai indiqué que
ce serait un des enseignements à mettre
en œuvre à l'issue de cette élection
mais il y aura bien entendu beaucoup
d'autres choses à faire je pose une
question à François mitteran qui est
dans la ligne de celle-ci si vous êtes
élu président de la République vous avez
dit que vous formeriez un gouvernement
ce gouvernement se présentera-t-il
devant l'Assemblée
nationale j'aurais voulu poser une
question à Monsieur François mitteran
sur la question de Monsieur giscardestin
parce que Monsieur François mitteran a
déjà eu l'occasion de dire que il ne
serait pas le seul contraint de
dissoudre l'Assemblée si vous étiez élu
il m'intéresserait de savoir en votre
présence comment il argumente sur ce
point après avoir entendu ce qui vient
d'être dit par Monsieur liscardestin
j'avais moi aussi envie de lui poser une
question selon les règles qui ont été
établies ce sera donc une question
indirecte qui sera quand même entendue
et je voulais simplement qu'on
m'explique c'est-à-dire que l'autre
candidat bien m'explique
son raisonnement n'est-il pas ne
tombe-t-il pas dans le
vide le 17 mai
1974 vous
déclariez c'était une autre élection
présidentielle il y a 7 ans je vous
demande de me croire vous vous adressez
aux Français vous ne serez pas déçu vous
serez surpris par l'ampleur par l'audace
par la rapidité du changement que je
veux introduire dans la politique de
notre pays et voilà que celui que vous
proclamez comme votre partenaire avec
lequel vous n'avez jamais une ennuie
peut-être quelques trouble dans la
majorité en tout cas jamais de motion de
censure voilà que Monsieur Chirac
responsable du RPR vous répond le 22
mars 1981 au Club de la Presse
d'OPA la France est dans une situation
extraordinairement difficile je suis
certain que la voie que nous suivrons si
monsieur giscardestin était réélu serait
la même et conduirait encore plus vite à
des désordres plus
graves deème citation il y en aura pas
beaucoup toujours Monsieur Jacques
Chirac
9 mars 1981 à l'émition carte surtable
d'Antenne 2 nous sommes dans une
situation extrêmement préoccupante qui
exige un changement complet de politique
et on ne change pas de politique avec
les mêmes
hommes une troisème sitituation très
rapide toujours du même monsieur Chirac
en date du 4 mars 1981
oui je porte un jugement négatif sur le
septena sans doute monsieurardestin
considérez-vous que Monsieur Chirac fait
partie du cœur des pleureuse mais il
n'empêche que j'aperçoise une
contradiction entre votre apparente
tranquillité d'il y a un moment sur
l'avenir de votre majorité pour peu que
vous soyez élu et des déclarations aussi
contradictoire qui montre que si vous
êtes élu vous n'avez pas de
majorité vousavez r à la question une
réponse à
apporter je constitueraiis un
gouvernement comme je le
dois après mon élection quand le moment
sera venu d'assumer mes
responsabilités ce gouvernement sera
composé des personnes femmes et hommes
que j'aurais choisi ou dont je
discuterai avec le Premier ministre que
j'aurais choisi
ces personnes seront celles qui auront
approuvé mes options pendant la campagne
présidentielle je ne serais pas en état
de débattre ou de discuter pour la
raison que la campagne présidentielle
m'absorbe qu'elle requiert entièrement
mon attention que c'est à elle que je
dois me consacrer qu'elle est d'une
nature particulière que ce n'est pas
l'affaire des
partis et je constituerai ce
gouvernement après la désignation du
Premier ministre de telle sorte que
celles et ceux qui m'auront approuvé
dans ma démarche à moi candidat des
socialistes puisse s'y retrouver je
seraai ainsi assuré de la cohérence de
ce
gouvernement vous savez que d'autres
formations politique nombreuses m'ont
rejoint pour le deè tour de
scrutin et bien entendu la question qui
m'est posé est-ce que vous ferez appel
aux représentants de ces partis et
particulièrement du Parti communiste
pour rentrer dans ce gouvernement et je
rappellerai à cet égard que si l'union
de la gauche s'est rompue en
1977 c'est précisément autour de la
discussion sur un programme de
gouvernement je ne peux donc pas
considérer à l'heure actuelle que cette
question soit réglé et c'est une
question sérieuse la plus sérieuse de
toutes j'entends donc former un
gouvernement qui sera constitué avec par
ceux qui m'auront approuvé et ce n'est
qu'après après l'élection présidentielle
et en vue des élections législatives
dont nous allons parler j'imagine tout à
l'heure que les organisations politiques
responsables et examineront en commun si
ell le désir si elles sont en mesure ou
non de signer entre elles un contrat de
gouvernement et donc d'aborder les
élections législatives futures en
situation
d'accord quant au gouvernement que
j'aurai constitué qui sera tout
simplement le gouvernement de la
République il se trouvera devant le
problème
suivant est-ce que il y aura dis
solution décidé par le Président de la
République immédiatement et dans ce
cas-là il n'aura pas à se présenter
devant l'Assemblée nationale ou bien
est-ce qu'il ya devant l'Assemblée
nationale en attendant la sanction de
cette assemblée pour peu qu'il y ait
sanction d'ailleurs ce qui veut dire que
je ne compte pas soumettre la politique
de ce
gouvernement à l'approbation de
l'Assemblée nationale élue en
si je changeais d'avis c'est-à-dire si
j'avais le sentiment que cette assemblée
serait en mesure par exemple de vootter
une réforme du mode de scrutin ce qui
serait très intéressant pour la France
vous êtes favorable j'y serai favorable
dans quel sens je souhaite le scrutin
proportionnel tout de suite le plutôt
sera le mieux vous aussi monsieur non
pas du
touton si j'étais en mesure de le faire
je le ferais cela veut dire que je ne p
pas le problème de la dissolution en
principe c'est simplement une nécessité
car je veux conduire ma politique alors
il y aura des élections et le peuple
décidera alors d'abord vos premiè
remarqu vous ave fait des citations du
premier tour dans le premier tour chacun
s'exprime avec une certaine véhémence
bon vousz trouver les citations à cet
égard je pourrais trouver également les
citations monsieur mitérant je n'en
cherche pas n'est-ce pas à votre propos
ou de vous-même sur monsieur Chirac j'en
ai une sous les yeux je ne la LAI même
pas tellementelle est sévère donc
laissons cela m'intéresse pas en fait
monsieur Chirac a indiqué dès le
lendemain du premier tour oui monsieur
mit VZ dire un mot est-ce si vous
l'autorisez monsieur je veux dire que
personnellement je ne compte pas faire
un gouvernement avec Monsieur Chirac
pour von élection pour le problème ne se
pose pas pour moi non mais je veux dire
quand on
invoque le témoignage de quelqu'un
encore faut-il porter sur ce quelqu'un
jugement positif alors j'indique
simplement que le lendemain du premier
tour monsieur Chirac a indiqué qu'il
voterait pour moi à l'élection
présidentielle pour moi le critère comme
d'ailleurs vous l'indiquez pour vous
tout à l'heure ce sont ceux qui élisent
le président de la République et je note
je les fait obserit tout à l'heure que
la totalité des dirigeants de la
majorité des parlementaires de majorité
avaiit indiqué qu'il voteraiit désormais
pour le président de la République donc
la question de ma majorité quand je dis
ma ce n'est pas un ma possessif est
réglé il n'y aura pas de dissolution un
gouvernement sera constitué ce
gouvernement bien entendu comportera des
personnalités représentatives de
l'ensemble de la majorité
et il se mettra au travail pour régler
par priorité et pour adopter les
premiers textes concernant l'emploi et
notamment l'emploi des jeunes que je
voudrais voir figurer à la session
parlementaire de printemps mais la
réponse à ma question la réponse que
vous avez faite me surprend énormément
monsieur mitteran nous ne sommes pas
dans un régime présidentiel ou personnel
vous m'avez fait des reproches à cet
égard dans le passé vous en avez fait
encore plus au général de Gaulle j'ai là
un certain nombre de textes mais la
Constitution dit que le gouvernement
responsable devant le Parlement si vous
agissez ainsi que vous dites
c'est-à-dire si votre gouvernement ne va
pas devant le Parlement il ne pourra
rien faire il n'aura le droit de ne rien
faire il devra attendre le résultat des
élections nous n'avons pas en France un
système tel qu'un président de la
République vous ou moi ou d'ailleurs le
général de Gaul dans le passé puisse
nommer un gouvernement qui ne rend de
compte à personne et qui prend des
décisions importantes ceci est
impossible si donc il ne va pas devant
le Parlement il pourra faire qu'une
chose qu'est-ce ce qu'on appelle vous
connaissez la formule expédier les
affair courante or j'ai lu dans vos
déclarations je crois que c'est à
L'Express il me semble que vous aviez
l'intention de prendre tout de suite un
certain nombre de mesures vous dites par
exemple réduction du taux de la TVA sur
les produits de grande consommation
recrutement d'un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires ce sont des décision
qu'un gouvernement chargé des affaires
courantes ne peut pas prendre donc la
procédure que vous indiquez n'est pas
réalisable le gouvernement doit aller
devant l'Assemblée l'assemblée peut ou
non le censurer vous pourriez comme
président de la République la souv
ensuite à tout moment mais j'estime
qu'un gouvernement pour pouvoir exister
en France il n'a jamais eu d'exemple de
sens contraire doit aller devant le
Parlement nous sommes dans un régime où
existe le contrôle parlementaire et
j'ajoute ensuite qu'il y aura
d'importantes négociations
internationales au moin de juin
notamment pour l'Europe imaginez-vous un
gouvernement français qui aille dans les
enceintes internationales alors qu'on
saura qu'il a été nommé par le Président
de la République et qui n'a même pas eu
un contact avec la représentation
nationale si c'est la formule que vous
choisissez il exp payira les affaires
courantes c'estàdire qu'il règle les
petits problèmes du quotidien il ne peut
prendre aucune décision importante
engageant la France Monsieur mitant
souhaite répondre sur ce point monsieur
bar que vous avez nommé a mis 41 jours à
se présenter devant l'Assemblée
nationale je va dire par là que pendant
41 jours il a bien fallu qu'il fasse
quelque chose non ah il n'a rien fait il
il a il a géré les affaires courantes
c'est une tradition monsieur mitant et
cela veut dire dans ce cas-là c'est un
point important que votre dissolution
elle ne pourra intervenir que mi-juin ou
fin juin parce que si vous regardez le
calendrier comme je l'ai fait avec soin
vous savez que l'installation du nouveau
président de la République se fait à un
jour près il y a un petit problème en
discussion vers le 25 ou 26 mai qui est
l'anniversaire de ma prise de fonction
et la convocation de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est début juin il y a
quelques jours nécessaires d'autant plus
que c'est la senstion à ce moment-là le
gouvernement va devant l'Assemblée
nationale s'il met du temps à y aller
comme l'avait fait monsieur bar ça veut
dire que votre dissolution ne peut
intervenir qu'à la mi-juin et que donc
les Français voteront à la mi-juillet ou
fin juillet est réaliste le président de
la République peut dissoudre quand il le
veut et je dissoudrai quand je le
déciderai et à ce moment-là je ne serai
pas dans l'obligation de vous rendre
compte j'agirai selon mes devoirs et la
Constitution croyez-moi elle sera
respectée j'ai l'intention de dissoudre
et j'ai l'intention de faire procéder à
des élections avant le 1er juillet s'il
a un argument majeur s'opposit à cela de
toute manière ma décision serait
maintenue je veux dire par là que je ne
serais pas en mesure de garder cette
assemblée et le problème pour moi serait
de disposer d'une majorité parce qu'on
ne peut pas mener une autre politique
sans une autre majorité quant au délis
monsieur giscardestin je verrai bien
mais supposons que il y ait la moindre
raison qui puisse m'être objecter par
d'autres juristes que par vous comme je
suis né légaliste je le resterai cela ne
m'empêchera pas élu président de la
République de mener la politique que
j'entendrai mener bien entendu avec le
Parlement dès qu'il sera là
ou vous êtes bien changeant monsieur
Vérant parce qu' y a quelques instants
vous nous aviez dit que vous ne saviez
pas si vous dissouderiez tout de suite
que vous étiez prêt à voir si sur un
sujet tel que par exemple la loi
électorale le Parlement ne pourrait pas
plus ou moins en délibérer puis vous
revenez tout à coup en arrière vous
dites je dissoudrai tout de suite et
même avec une précipitation très grande
car si vous voulez faire les élections à
la fin du mois de juin il faut que le
premier acte de votre septenna soit la
dissolution vous n'avez pas le temps
d'aller devant le Parlement étudier le
problème et donc vous prendrez en
arrivant un décret de dissolution vous
ferez donc ce qu'a fait jadis macmon
c'est-à-dire que sans avoir que sans
avoir rencontrer la représentation
nationale sans même qu'un gouvernement
sohait aller lui dire voilà mon
programme vous direz Messieurs les
Députés je vous renvoie chez vous ce qui
veut dire d'ailleurs que les conditions
de l'élection et la signification pour
le président de la République seront
très fortes car si vous renvoyez les
députés sans même qu'ils aient eu droit
à un exposé de la politique de votre
gouvernement et au la possibilité
d'exprimer la censure ensuite si le
souvrage universel renvoie les mêmes
c'est un des aveux au président de la
République il ne faut pas confondre avec
la situation de 78 dont nous avions
débattu quand il y a une élection
normale en France si elle envoie une
majorité différente le président de la
République doit en tirer un certain
nombre de conséquences il doit avec
sagesse essayer de trouver une formule
mais si le président de la République
prend l'initiative et vous venez de le
dire de renvoyer la représentation
parlementaire sans même la réunir et si
la même représentation parlementaire
revient quelle est l'autorité quelle est
la situation du président de la
République et en tout cas dans
l'intervalle dans l'intervalle le
gouvernement ainsi formé ne peut
qu'expédier les affaires courantes il ne
peut entreprendre aucune des grandes
actions ou aucune des grandes décisions
que vous avez évoqué dans vos
déclarations récent monsieurardestin en
ce qui concerne l'expédition des
affaires courantes je voudrais que vous
puiez préciser avec Monsieur mitteran
des points trois points précis parce que
Monsieur Marchet a déclaré au lendemain
du Comité central du Parti communiste
qu'il attendait d'un gouvernement de
gauche trois mesures précises la hausse
du SMIC le blocage des prix la
revalorisation des allocations
familiales est-ce que sur ces trois
mesures précises un gouvernement ne peut
pas agir sans avoir recours à
l'Assemblée
nationale je ne voudrais pas si vous
permettez que nous passions notre temps
à nous comporter un juriste compliqué
disputant de choses que beaucoup de
français risquent de ne pas aimer dans
la mesure où ça les ennuiera je suis
quelqu'un qui a toujours respecté la loi
et je la respecterai j'ajoute que comme
vous serez à ce moment-là ancien
président de la République vous ferez
partie du comité constitutionnel et vous
pourrez dire votre du Conseil
constitutionnel et vous pourrez dire
votre
mot sur TR sur les trois problèmes que
je viens d'évoquer est-ce que les
décisions peuvent être prises sans la
accord du Parlement et est-ce que vous
les prendriez plusieurs de ces mesures
sont d'ordre
réglementaire c'est-à-dire sont de
l'autorité du gouvernement nous les
retrouverons tout à l'heure le
gouvernement c'est toujours le
gouvernement de la République toujours
ce sont des points très importants n
nallons pas y rester j'ai des questions
plus importantes encore à vous poser
mais ce sont des questions importantes
car il ne faut pas faire croire aux
Français que vous aurez le pouvoir de
prendre en mai ou en juin des décisions
que vous ne pourrez pas prendre parce
que légalement vous ne pourvez le
prendre quand vous dites par exemple je
baisserai la TVA sur les produits de
consommation courrante vous n'aurez pas
le droit de le faire oui mais on
peutmenter le SMIC Montin alors le SMIC
on peut le fixer et on peut bloquer les
prix et c'est à la limite on on n jamais
pris dans des périodes qui ne sont que
des périodes électorales des décisions
qui bouleversent les conditions de
l'activité c'est contraire à la coutume
mais ce n'est pas contraire à la lo
c'est contraire à la coutume et une
décision de cette nature serait
d'ailleurs très vivement critique alors
deuxème question à Monsieur bteran il y
a donc des élections si comme vous le
dites vous renvoyez l'Assemblée
nationale c'est parce que vous voulez
avoir une autre majorité et cette autre
majorité on voit bien de qui elle est
composée elle est composée des 26 %
d'électeurs que vous avez eu dont
d'ailleurs quelques points de communiste
et puis il faut trouver 24 ou 25 autres
donc la totalité de l'électorat
communiste comme nous avons un scrutin
d' arrondissement à deux tours vous
revenez de dire à l'instant que vous
dissolvier tout de suite donc il n'y a
pas de changement de doit électoral il
faut un accord électoral vous n'allez
pas le faire avec vous avez chassé vous
le ferez donc avec ceux qui vous les
ramener c'est-à-dire avec le Parti
communiste quelles sont les conditions
que le Parti communiste vous demandera
pour aboutir à un tel accord électoral
et deuxièmement quand vous aurez nommé
votre premier ministre ensuite et qu'il
viendra vous dire Monsieur le Président
de la République voilà la liste des
ministres et je vous propose des
ministres communistes quelle sera votre
réponse j'ai déjà répondu à au premiè
élément de la question posée non pas
spécialement par vous mais par l'opinion
publique que j'ai souvent entendu poser
tout le long de cette campagne j'ai
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'y répondre au
cours des multiples débats qui m'ont
conduit au postes de télévision ou au
postees de radiodiffusion et j'ai dit ce
que je répète car j'ai déjà abordé de
moi-même ce sujet que le premier
gouvernement que je constituerai sera
composé des femmes et des hommes qui se
seront engager sur les options du
candidat des socialistes que je suis
toujours bien entendu à partir du moment
où les élections législatives devront
être préparées il appartiendra aux
organisations politiques responsables
vous savez que les partis politiques
existent ont des droits sont reconnus
par la Constitution à son article 4 même
quand le président de la République les
met gravement en cause et ces
organisations politique se rencontreront
discuteront est-ce que les partis de
gauche notamment socialistes et
communistes seront en mesure
d'aboutir c'est-à-dire à signer un
accord de
gouvernement à s'entendre pour la
suite je le saurai à ce moment-là est-ce
qu'ils auront réussi à vaincre les
obstacles qui les ont dominés en
1977 c'est cette discussion sérieuse
qu'il faut engager que j'ai toujours
souhaité en tant que responsable du
parti socialiste hier donc cette
discussion aura lieu les organisations
politiques décideront souverainement
elles-même de ce qu'ell doit faire
c'est-à-dire de leurs accords ou de leur
désaccords et si elles sont d'accord
il appartiendra aux Français de choisir
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les Français
qui auront le dernier mot puisqu'ils
voteront pour l'élection des députés à
ce moment-là je pourrait vous apporter
la réponse mais je voudrais vous dire à
moins que vous n'ayez déjà des
objections à me faire sur ce sujet que
cette question sans cesse posée donc
j'aperçois bien pourquoi elle l' je
trouve ça très intéressant parce que moi
j'ai l' de parler de façon très claire
très claire cela fait déjà très
longtemps que je me suis battu dans ce
pays pour tenter de réussir l'union de
la gauche et je n'ai jamais désavoué ma
démarche simplement je me suis trouvé
devant une situation qui la rendait
impossible à partir de là j'ai dû le
constater mais les socialiste dont je ne
suis plus le premier responsable dont je
ne serai plus responsable ni membre mais
proche cependant une fois élu président
de la République ce parti socialiste
restera maître de cette décision et bien
entendu je pense qu'il restera lui aussi
fidèle à l'axe de sa politique qui tente
au rassemblement populaire autour de ses
objectifs voilà ce que j'entend
faire monsieur mitteran est-ce Queau
fond vous ne reculez pas pour mie sauter
est-ce que cet accord avec les
communistes que vous ne recherchez pas
entre le 1er et le 2è tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous allez le rechercher
dès que l'élection présidentielle sera
terminée ce n'est pas mon affaire comme
candidat élection présidentielle vous
vous trompez d'élection vous vous
trompez d'élection il s'agit d'élire un
président de la répuque
il ne s'agit pas pour l'instant de
constituer un gouvernement sur la base
d'une nouvelle majorité on élira d'abord
un président de la République ce
président de la République ensuite
indiquera à quel moment auront lieu des
élections législatives et ceux qui
voudront constituer une majorité dans un
camp comme dans l'autre se réunieront
pour en discuter voilà et à ce moment-là
bien entendu je tiendrai compte de ce
qui aura été décidé et je verrai bien
quelle majorité aura été adopté par les
français puisque ce sont les Français
qui décideront j'ai personnellement le
sentiment quiélu président de la
République c'est-à-dire disposant d'une
majorité la majorité elle se formera le
10 mai cette majorité-là elle aura une
force entraînante
formidable ce sera un événement vous
savez pour la France que l'élection d'un
président de la République socialiste et
le rassemblement qui se constituera euh
nous placera dans une situation
psychologique et politique différente de
celle d'aujourd'hui et j'espère en effet
que ce rassemblement populaire se
constituera et si la majorité n'est est
pas conforme à ce que vous en attendez
gouvernerez avec je suis un démocrate ce
momentlà je serais contraint de répondre
que Monsieur GIS cardestin a Verdin sur
le dou lorsqu'il pouvait redouter la
victoire de la gauche en
1978 j'appliquerai la loi et je resterai
là où je suis en essayant de veiller aux
intérêts de la France de mon mieux
monsieur on ne peut pas défendre des
théories de cette nature je vous le dis
très franchement d'abord on peut pas
conduire un peuple les vieux bandés
c'est un peuple majeur qui doit savoir
où il va vous venez de nous dire il y a
quelques minutes que vous prendriez une
décision tout de suite qui était de
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale parce
que vous ne pouvez pas travailler avec
la majorité qui existe que vous avez
qualifié de conservatrice donc vous
renvoyez les députés et vous nous dites
ensuite et bien on verra avec qui on
s'entendra mais on verra pas avec qui
puisque d lors que la majorité s'en va
vous êtes obligé de rechercher un accord
à l'intérieur de ceux qui vous auront
soutenu c'est-à-dire socialiste et
communiste il aucune autre alternative
et j'imagine qu'à l'heure actuelle vous
y avez réfléchi vous allez pas découvrir
le 15 juin qu'un accord entre les
socialistes et les communistes est
impossible alors qu'on sera au plein
milieu de l'élection que vous aurez
vous-même décidé et deuxièmement vous ne
pouvez pas dire au français je veux
conduire un grand changement avec
n'importe qui c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire y compris même
l'assemblée actuel parce que dans ce
cas-là ne la dissolvez pas et surtout si
vous voulez conduire un grand changement
avec n'importe qui c'est que vous ne
voulez pas conduire un grand changement
parce que vous savez très bien que le
projet socialiste que j'ai là qui est
d'ailleurs un texte important et dont
nous Lons tout à l'heure des extraits
c'est un changement important de la vie
de la France et que la majorité actuelle
non seulement n est pas favorable mais
est absolument hostile si donc votre
projet votre ambition c'est le projet
socialiste ou une formule voisine il
faut avoir une majorité pour le faire
j'imagine pas l'autorité ni intérieure
ni extérieure du président de la
République française et ça compte j'ai
porté le poids de cette fonction pendant
7 ans je n'imagine pas son autorité si
étant élu avec les voix communistes il
va revenir après avoir congédié le parle
Parlement une majorité qui lui soit
hostile et qui disent à ce moment-là
mais tout va bien je continue et je vais
diriger les affaires de la France c'est
totalement un vraisemblable à Verdin sur
le dou ce que j'avais dit c'est que dans
une échéance électorale normale le
président de la République en fonction a
le devoir de tenir compte de ce que
choisissent les électeurs mais s'il
prend l'initiative car si vous qui
prendez l'initiative de congédier le
Parlement et si l'opinion publique le
désavoue car c'est ça que ça veut dire
en en renvoyant une majorité de sens
inverse le président de la République
n'a plus aucune autorité et à mon avis
il ne peut pas rester et d'ailleurs à
mon avis il ne resterait pas dans une
autre situation ce serait différent la
vérité c'est que vous avez besoin d'une
majorité pour faire ce que vous voulez
faire et que cette majorité c'est
l'alliance d'Ille normale vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure des communistes et
des socialistes mais dans ce cas-là il
faut vous battre ouvertement pour dire
cette majorité il faut la il faut la
rassembler d'abord lors de l'élection
présidentielle et ensuite lors de
l'élection législative sinon nous
entrons dans un système politique de
désordre de confusion comme la France a
connu dans le passé et comme la 5è
République heureusement nous en a
délivré messieur je me permets
simplement de vous faire remarquer que
sur cette première partie de votre
discussion il reste à Monsieur mitteran
un peu moins de 3 minutes et à Monsieur
giscardestin un peu moins de 2 minutes
je voudrais
répondre monsieur
Jestin je souhaite gagner l'élection
présidentielle je pense la gagner mais
quand je l'aurai gagné je feraai tout ce
qu'il conviendra de faire dans le cadre
de la loi pour gagner les élections
législatives et si vous n'imaginez pas
ce que sera à partir de lundi prochain
l'état d'esprit de la France sa
formidable volonté de changement alors
c'est que vous ne comprenez rien à ce
qui se passe dans ce
pays et si tous ceux qui veulent se
rassembler autour du président de la
République élu le 10 mai veulent l'aider
par la suite de plus en plus N nombreux
à former la majorité législative
elle me trouvera à ses côtés quant à
votre dégagement disons antiommuniste
permettez-moi de vous dire qu'il
mériterait quelques correctifs car c'est
quand même un peu trop
facile comprenez les les les
travailleurs communistes sont nombreux
on finirait par croire dans votre
raisonnement à quoi servent-il ils
servent à à produire à travailler ils
servent à payer des impôts ils servent à
mourir dans les guerres ils servent à
tout mais ils ne peuvent jamais servir à
faire une majorité en
France la façon dont vous le dites
implique une sorte d'exclusion de la vie
nationale qui n'est pas dans mon état
d'esprit de telle sorte que si les
Français élisent une majorité lors des
élections législatives qui soit une
majorité de rassemblement populaire bien
entendu je travaillerai avec elle
monsieur mitéran êtes-vous satisfait de
voir le score du Parti communiste au
premier tour des élections président
financiel ramené à 15 % du corps
électoral pardon question complémentaire
à qui de vous deux cela fait-il le plus
plaisir moi je suis surtout satisfait
d'avoir atteint 26 % et bien entendu
quand on gagne des suffrages on les
prend à quelqu'un d'autre bon donc je
n'ai pas passé de temps à déplorer les
difficultés des autres bien entendu j'ai
fait le compte et je souhaiterais que
les forces de la gauche soient encore
plus puissantes et je pense que des un
certain nombre de femmes et d'hommes qui
n'étaient pas encore des nôtres le 26
avril viendront nous rejoindre le 10mi
parce qu'ils sentent bien que c'est de
ce côté-là que se trouve l'avenir
c'est-à-dire le changement mon répondre
d'abord vous avez eu 26 % des voix pour
employer l'expression d'un journal qui a
pu votre candidature vous avez donc été
désavoué par 74 % des Français puisil
dit que moi j'étais désavoué par je m
combien 72 mais je n'attaque pas du tout
l'électorat communiste en 7 ans Monsieur
mitteran j'ai jamais eu un mot
désobligeant pour la classe ouvrière
France française jamais je la respecte
dans son travail dans son activité et
même dans son expression politique c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs dans
de grandes régions industrielle elle m'a
placé devant vous lors des dernières
élections mais ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est qu'il faut que vous annonciez
vos couleurs et moi j'annonce mes
couleur vous venez de nous dire et j'en
prends acte que vous souhaitez le succès
d'une majorité de socialistes et de
communistes lors des prochaines
élections législatives il faut que c
français le sachent ça n'est pas du tout
faire grillef aux électeurs de choisir
cette majorité il faut que les Français
le sachent parce que ce que vous appelez
le rassemblement c'est une nébuleuse et
cette nébuleuse il y a un noyau central
qu'on connaît bien c'est l'ancienne
union de la gauche c'est-à-dire
l'entente des socialistes et des
communistes et puis alors a autour il y
a la nébuleuse de ce qu'on peut tromper
pendant un certain temps et je ne veux
pas qu'il y ait de français trompés donc
si vous dites que vous souhaitez le
succès d'une majorité de socialiste et
du communiste c'est parfaitement clair
je ne vous en fais pas le reproche mais
je demande que ceci soit bien entendu et
compris par nos concitoyens
vous trompez nos concitoyens lorsque
vous prétendez avoir une majorité ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure de la pensée
exprimé de Monsieur Chirac au sujet de
votre septenéna la dureté de ces propos
le sentiment de votre échec et que le
changement de politique nécessaire
devrait entraîner un changement d'homme
et donc un changement de Président
permettez-moi de vous dire que Jacques
Chirak en a dit davantage si l'on peut
rendre à ce pays la confiance et
l'espoir fussent au prix de la défaite
du président République vous c'est
l'intérêt de la France qui m'importe et
non pas l'intérêt de tel ou tel homme y
compris le mien et c'est avec cela que
vous allez faire une majorité moi
j'entends en effet élu président de la
République entraîner la majorité des
Français qui aura voté pour moi le 10
mai c'est QFD le 10 mai si je suis élu
c'est bien que j'ai la majorité
pardonnez cette vérité de la Palise et
bien toutes celles et tous ceux-là qui
m'auront qui m'auront soutenu oui
j'essaierai de faire avec eux une
majorité pour les législatifs monsur
vous avez 17 secondes à récup z sur la
suite du débat car vous avez légèrement
débordé mais c'est tout à fait Conat
puisquau total 20 secondes je voulais
qu'il un point clair pour clarifier le
débat les Français attendent des
réponses si vous êtes élu président de
la République vous souhaiterez
l'élection d'une majorité composée de
socialistes et de communiste lors des
élections législatives qu'entraîneront
la dissolution immédiate de l'Assemblée
nationale je voulais que ce point soit
connu je souhaiterais battre les forces
conservatrices qui ont marqué sous votre
conduite le déclin de la France et bien
nous allons y venir puisque nous
abordons les questions économiques et
que dans ce domaine vous avez chacun un
passé monsieur valerrygis cardestin a le
passé d'un homme qui a été Président de
la République pendant 7 ans et donc un
bilan que certains jugent bon d'autres
médiocre voire
désastreux monsieur miteran a le passé
de ses idées de ses alliances et de ses
amis le programme commun de à gauche
pendant un temps le projet socialiste
aujourd'hui et je voulais vous demander
monsieur giscardestin si vous vous
sentez prisonnier des échec de votre SEP
et Monsieur mitteran si vous vous sentez
prisonnier des idées que certains ont
définis comme étant des idées
collectivistes monsieur jiscardest bon
pas simplification abusive la France a
vécu pendant 7 ans une période de crise
mondiale très difficile j'en ai porté le
poids j'en ai porté le poids j'en assume
les responsabilités je ne ni rien de ce
qui a été fait au cours de cette période
qui était vous le savez monsieur
boissona vous l'avez écrit pluss
reprises vous entends une période de
crise la seule question n'est pas de
savoir si la France a pu se soustraire à
la crise elle ne le pouvait pas
j'indique qu'elle ne le peut pas non
plus maintenant la question est de
savoir si elle fait tout ce qu'elle peut
compte tenu de ses ressources et de sa
politique propre et je vous rappelle que
dans cette période de crise le produit
la production française a augmenté plus
que celle de tout autre pays
industrialisé que le niveau de vie le
pouvoir at des Français a progressé plus
que dans n'importe quel autre pays
industrialisé et que malgré la crise
nous avons réalisé des actions de
solidarité envers des catégories
démunies personnes âgées handicapé
travailleurs manuels famille femme seul
donc je considère qu'un pays ce n'est
pas moi qui l'ai fait qu'un pays qui
fait cela pendant une période de crise
la plus forte augmentation de la
production la plus forte augmentation du
niveau de vie et un effort de solidarité
il a montré ce dont il était capable il
y a deux grands revers de grandes
difficulté la hausse des prix et le
chômage et nous avons entrepris dans ce
domaine des actions vous savez qu'à
l'heure actuelle la hausse des prix
reste trop forte en France mais qu'elle
diminue et je suis convaincu que le
programme tel que je l'ai lu exposé par
Monsieur mitteran relancerait
immédiatement l'inflation à la hausse
des prix tout prêt à en débattre et
d'autre part en matière de chômage nous
avons entrepris une action depuis
plusieurs années cette action peut se
développer j'en ai indiqué les modalités
et les conditions donc je prends la
responsabilité de ce qui a été fait je
me fuis aucune responsabilité j'indique
seulement que les efforts que nous avons
accomplis seraient compromis excusezmi
ruinés si le programme tel qu'il est
présenté par Monsieur miteran entit en
application l'été prochain monsieur
miteran vous êtes prisonnier des idées
socialistes en la matière mais je dois
quand même répondre à ce qui a été dit
par monsieurardestin avant de développer
ma propre TR enans quoi on risque de
s'embouiller je tiens simplement à dire
monsieurardestin que vous vous êtes
toujours trompé on ne peut plus vous
croire
j'ai encore des questions à vous poser
et je voudrais comme je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure expliquez-moi expliquez-nous je
veux dire expliquez aux françaises et
aux Français qui nous écoute lorsque
vous disiez en
74 je prendrai c'est l'État au moment
des promesses des promesses électorales
je prendrai toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour garantir votre emploi à
vous salariés à vous travailleurs à vous
ouvriers et aussi pour garantir votre
revenu à vous épargnant à vous
agriculteurs lorsque vous disiez
toujours pendant votre septena en 78
c'est grâce à cet effort le vôtre que la
France n'est pas comme d'autres pays sur
la voie d'un accroissement du chômage
mais qu'au contraire elle a pu entamer
une réduction significative du nombre
des demandeurs d'emploi c'était le 26
janvier 1978 à os lorsque vous disiez
dans le même discours l'emploi en
particulier celui des jeunes ne cesse de
s'améliorer on nous prédisit 1 million
et demi de chômeurs ils seront bientôt
moins d'un million on en comp toujours
'h 1700000 lorsque vous disiez un
certain nombre de signes qui ne trompe
pas montre que le creux de la vague est
derrière nous le 4 décembre
1975 vous vous êtes toujours trompé et
comment imaginez que vous pourriez faire
demain si vous étiez réélu ce que vous
n'avez pas su faire au cours d'un
premier septenal C ans c'est long ça
permet de faire beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs monsieur chira que c'est la
fin de mes citations toujours
expliquez-moi comment vous pourriez
faire une majorité dans ces conditions
avec avec le RPR monsieur Chirac déclaré
le 2 février 1979 nos performances
économiques dont vous parissiez tout à
l'heure si satisfait nos performances
économiques sur tous les points sont
très médiocres sur ce point je me je ne
me disocie pas de monsieur miteran qui
fait la même analyse et le même
diagnostic alors je termine sur ce sujet
en disant que j'ai là un texte qui été
publié par la fédération patronale
française de la métallurgie dans son
mensuel social international et qui dit
que au championnat du monde de
l'économie parmi les 15 principaux pays
industriels la France se situe en 13e
rang cela n'est pas la preuve d'une très
grande
réussite maintenant question m'est posée
sur le collectivisme non non maintenant
je va je vais répondre d'une phrase oui
oui question après cette ch je comprends
très bien euh vous me faites penser au
mot de Rivarol c'est un terrible
avantage de n'avoir rien fait mais il ne
faut pas en abuser en effet vous gérez
le ministère de la parole ceci depuis
1965 ou depuis 1974 moi j'ai géré la
France vous faites d'abondant de
citations de Jacques Chirac pourquoi ne
citez-vous pas une seule fois le nom de
Monsieur Marchet depuis le début de
cette émission ce serait plus
intéressant il apporterait des éléments
plus proches de votre analyse et
concernant les performances économiques
j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre à un
président de la République il doit
entraîner son pays ne doit pas le
décourager il est donc naturel qu'à tout
moment il cherche à lui proposer des
objectifs de redressement ou
d'amélioration s'il fallait rentrer dans
le détaat nous ne le ferons pas je vous
rappellerai que ce que je disais en 1978
était exact il y a eu deux chocs
pétroliers monsieur Bor n'explique pas
tout mais ils ont été branlé notre
économie le premier a eu lieu en 73 74
et nous commencions à en sortir dans les
années 77 78 monsieur boissonard je vous
prends un témoin nous avions à l'époque
une diminution en effet légère du
chômage la hausse des prix était tombée
au-dessous de 10 % nous avions une
croissance supérieure à 3 % par an nous
étions en train d'en sortir vous savez
sans doute qu'il a eu un second choc
pétrolier à la suite des événements
d'Iran et ceci à partir de la MI79 et
qui a relancé à nouveau toutes les
difficultés économique et le chômage et
je me suis efforcé face au premier et
face au second de redresser la situation
de la France nous avions obtenu un
premier redressement dans les années 77
78 il est incontestable nous sommes
actuellement à l'heure actuelle en train
de nous dégager lentement du second choc
pétrolier j'avais des résultats
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la balance des
paiements de la France pour le prier
trimestre de 81 il y a un net progrès
par rapport à 1980 donc ne recherchons
pas les citations du passé dans lequel
vous vous complaisez je nurais pas la
cruauté de vous relire ce que vous
disiez quand vous appeliez à la
réalisation du programme commun avant
1978 ou lorsque vous opposiez la
Constitution de 1958 dont vous cherchez
être maintenant le président de la
République donc ceci c'est le passé nous
devons éclairer les Français sur ce que
nous allons faire nos choix pour
l'avenir j'ai proposé un problème un
programme pour l'emploi critiquez-le
mais nous ne jouons pas à ce petit jeu
des citation peut-être qu'avant de venir
à l'emploi nous pouvons demander à
Monsieur mittiran de répondre à la
critique de ceux qui lui reprochent
d'être prisonnier soit encore du
programme commun ou tout au moins de sa
philosophie qu'il croit retrouver dans
le projet socialiste et je prends un
seul exemple celui des nationalisations
parce que c'est celui qui est le plus
public est-ce que vous avez toujours le
programme de nationalisation et si vous
pensez que ça résoudra le problème des
entreprises que vous entendez
nationaliser et comment serait un iser
les propriétaires actuels de ces
entreprises vous ne voulez pas parler du
passé je comprends bien
naturellement et vous avez tendance un
peu à reprendre le refrain d'il y a 7
ans l'homme du passé c'est quand même
ennuyeux que dansinterval vous soyez
devenu vous l'homme du passif cela gêne
un peu votre démonstration
d'aujourd'hui vous m'avez reproché
d'avoir exercé une sorte de ministère de
la parole mais moi j'étais dans
l'opposition j'ai rempli mon rôle
démocratiquement dans l'opposition
qu'est-ce que voulez que je fasse
d'autrre et l'opposition céit pas rien
dans une république j'ajoute que j'ai
utilisé ce temps pour faire avec
d'autres un grand parti qui est devenu
un parti menaçant pour la majorité
presque ancienne que vous représentez
aujourd'hui donc j'ai pas perdu mon
temps et si je pouvais faire pour la
France demain à la mesure de la France
bien entendu ce que j'ai pu faire pour
le socialisme en France ma fois ce ne
serait pas perdu les deux chocs
pétrolier c'est vrai bien entendu c'est
pas la peine de prendre un ton
professoral pour dire on l'a remarqué
figurez-vous qu'on l'a remarqué nous
aussi qu' y avait deux chocs pétroliers
et je ne suis pas de ceux qui onont dire
que le coût du pétrole ne compte pas et
lourdement dans les difficultés qui sont
nres mais tout rejeté sur le pétrole ce
n'est pas vrai ce n pas moême je ne rej
pas mais la part est plus grande encore
que celle que vous vous entendiez sur le
plan de l'inflation le pétrole pèse
lourd mais disons 3 % sur les presque 14
% de l'année
1980 de telle sorte qu'il faut que vous
vous expliquiez aussi c le faire dans
les 3 jours qui restent sur votre
responsabilité dans la vie chère en
France mais j'en reviens maintenant à la
question que vous m'avez posé après
avoir simplement fait remarquer que la
Grande-Bretagne qui produit du pétrole
eu est dans une grave crise et que le
Japon qui n'en produit pas supporte très
bien le choc de la concurrence
internationale ce qui démolit pour une
part le raisonnement de vous interrom qu
un mot vous plaît simplement
l'Angleterre n'arrive pas à se remettre
des conséquences de la gestion
travailliste c'est-à-dire socialiste
dont elle a souffert pendant 5 ans et le
Japon au contraire stimulé par son
économie libérale est en effet capable
de se dégager du choc pétrolier ce n'est
pas exact du tout la crise avait
commencé avec les conservateurs et les
deux pays qui en Europe sentir le mieux
aujourd'hui sont un pays à gestion
socialiste l'Autriche et un pays qui
dont la gestion socialiste fut si longue
qu'elle pèse encore sur les décisions du
gouvernement qui leur a succédé je veux
dire la Suède mais on ne va pas
s'attarder sur cette discussion nos
auditeurs concluront demain ce que je
veux dire c'est que pour ce qui concerne
le programme commun et la liste des
nationalisations qui y figurent bien
entendu elle se trouve un peu euh
contredite par l'événement dans la
mesure où vous le savez certain nombre
de ces sociétés que l'on ne voulait pas
que je nationalise ont été dans
l'intervalle internationalisé par le
grand capital je pense en particulier à
Rousel luukf et à certaines branches
mais ça c'est un problème très actuel
euh de péchiné mais la liste en question
reste la liste que je retiens en effet
je compte
nationaliser les les banques ce qui
reste non nationalisé depuis la
nationalisation des banques exécutées
par toutes les banques monsieur mit les
banques les banques toutes les banques
le général et petites le général de GA
avait fait l'essentiel en 1945 il avait
regretté en 1947 de ne pas avoir tout
fait et bien il m'incombra de le faire à
mon tour et 11 je crois groupes
industriels ce que j'entends dire c'est
c'est que la liste que j'ai déjà
produite c'est à valeur de contrat ce
qui veut dire que qui n'est pas dans
cette liste ne sera pas nationnalisé si
plus tard il devait y avoir des
évolutions il y en aura c'est-à-dire de
nouvelles concentrations capitalistes
tendant au monopole dans des secteurs
clés de l'économie alors il appartiendra
euh à au Parlement lors de futures
élections c'est-à-dire lorsque les
Français seront en mesure de souscrire
un nouveau contrat avec les responsables
politiques mais tant que je serai
responsable dans la situation présente
la liste est une liste limitative
monsieur mit m'autorisez-Vous une
question plus personnelle je vous en
prie est-ce que quand vous dites c'est
un contrat je le respecte vous voulez
signifiez par là qu'il y a des symboles
en politique qui ont leur importance et
qu'il faut savoir plier à ces symboles
telle ou telle appréciation
d'opportunité que l'on peut avoir
autrement dit êtes-vous vous au fond de
vous-même convaincu qu'en faisant cela
pour résolver des problèmes de la France
ou
convaincu qu'en faisant cela vous créez
un symbole autour duquel vous pouvez
réunir des forces qui permettront de
résoudre d'autres problèmes non monsieur
boisson je suis convaincu que le
gouvernement de la France aura le plus
grand besoin pour conduire l'économie
d'un vaste secteur public qui déjà
aujourd'hui est la véritable locomotive
de l'investissement et de l'exportation
en France et lorsqu'il y a lorsqu'il y a
des secteurs importants où la
concurrence a cessé d'exister c'estàd où
le grand capital est dévoré de petit et
moyennes entreprises je pense qu'il
appartient à la nation d'intervenir
monsieur jiscardestin pour en arriver au
problème de l'emploi vous avez dit et
vous avez redit tout à l'heure que
c'était à vos yeux un échec du SEPA
alors vous avez rendu public un plan
pour l'emploi mais en essayant de
résumer tout à l'heure avec Jean
boissena on avait l'impression que vous
déplacez les emplois que vous les
aménagez en quelque sorte mais que vous
n'en créez pas de nouveau est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire si nous nous
trompons
vous trompez naturellement tout à fait
je reviens en arrière pas pour noter il
faut noter les points forts de ce débat
les nationalisations donc monsieur
miteran s'il était élu président de la
République fera nationaliser l'ensemble
du système bancaire et 11 grands groupes
industriels c'est un point très
important j'ai fait véité ce que cela
représente cela veut dire que dans
l'industrie française il y aura 50 %
d'industrie nationalisée la France sera
nationalisée pour la moitié de son
industrie il n'y a aucun pays d'Europe
aucun pays occidental qui aura une telle
structure je le dis pour les
téléspectateurs parce que il croit que
la gestion de Monsieur miteran serait
apporterait quelques modification àel à
quelques conditions de vie pas du tout
nous serions dans une économie
socialisée à partir du moment où tout le
système du crédit est un système
étatique où la moitié de l'activité
industrielle est étatique c'est une
économie socialisée il faut le savoir et
ça permet de répondre à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure de Jacques Chirac
Monsieur vitérant Jacques Chirac nous
écoutons en vous écoutant et ayant
enregistré au cours de sa campagne au
contraire l'appel à la liberté d'une
grande partie du secteur productif
français notamment les petites et
moyennes entreprises et entendant cette
socialisation du crédit et de la moitié
de l'industrie française est en effet
porté par un mouvement spontané à
soutenir celui qui défend la conception
de la de liberté dans la vie économique
ce point là aussi le premier point tout
à l'heure était politique ce point je
crois qu'il faut que les Français le
connaissent je ne vous en fais pas
griief je vous ferai au contraire Grif
qui resta dans l'ombre à l'heure
actuelle on sait ce sera une société
plus bureaucratique la moitié de
l'industrie française sera étatisée car
c'est cela la la nationalisation la
totalité du système du crédit sera
également étatisée al je vous pose une
question par rapport à l'indépendance
pétrolière tout à l'heure pourquoi
voulez-vous arrêter le programme
électronucléaire français j'ai beaucoup
de questions à la fois il y a pas de
question prenez acte dans le début si
vous voulez bien y revenir tout à
l'heure mais je voudrais qu'on procède
par ordre ou nous pension y revenir
quand voulez qu'on parle de l'emploi
peut-être que nous reviendrons sur les
problèm énergéti B on reviendra sur les
problèm énergétiques je préciserai
d'ailleurs ma question alors nous Pons
pas commenter un dispositif général pour
l'emploi qu'est-ce que j'ai quel a été
le point central de mon dispositif c'est
qu'il arrive à l'heure actuelle 750000
jeunes sur le marché du travail en
France que cette arrivée des jeunes
n'est pas l'unique cause mais est un
facteur de déséquilibre de notre marché
du travail et qu'il faut donc offr des
emplois à la totalité des emplois ou des
formations à la totalité des jeunes
Français qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail com très différent offrir des
emplois ou des formations parce que si
vous offrez des formations au bout
desquelles il n'y a pas d'emploi ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose j'ai dit
des emplois ou des ou des formations ce
qui assure pour un jeune le fait que ou
bien il travaille ou bien il est en
formation et pendant ce temps le
développement d'activité économique ou
la reconquête de certains secteurs du
travail je suis le seul àir parler
problème de l'immigration en France
France permet de restituer ensuite des
emplois aux jeunes Français en fin de
formation lorsque j'ai été élu président
de la République il y avait encore un
grand nombre de jeunes Français qui
arrivaient sur le marché du travail sans
formation ce nombre a été réduit de plus
de moitié c'est à l'heure actuelle de
95000 et l'objectif que j'ai indiqué
c'est de le ramener à zéro l'expérience
montre que les jeunes Français et les
jeunes Françaises lorsqu'ils ont un
degré de formation suffisant et
lorsqu'il y a une bonne orientation des
circuits de formation trouvent des
emplois dans des conditions meilleur
donc c'est un plan cohérent qui repose
sur un certain nombre de mesures de mise
à la retraite mais la différence de
celle que propose monsieur miteran qui
sont générales par abaissement des
limites d'âge ce sont au contraire des
possibilités ouvertes par voie
conventionnelle parce que je considère
que d'ici quelques années la situation
du marché de l'emploi sera différente en
France à partir des années 85 et qu'il
faut garder une grande souplesse pour
que les Français puissent avoir une
liberté d'appréciation concernant l'âge
de la retraite donc il y aura un effort
de formation professionnelle un certain
nombre de possibilités ouvertes
concernant des possibilités de retraite
par
anticipation dans la fonction publique
possibilité de retraite par anticipation
pour créer des recrutements mais sans
augmenter le nombre total de
fonctionnairees et enfin stimulation de
l'activité économique dans un certain
nombre de secteurs de pointe ce que nous
avons déjà fait pour aboutir à la
création d'emplois nouveaux monsieur
mitéran vous avez vous aussi vos projets
en matière d'emploi et peut-être
voulez-vous réagir à celui de Monsieur
il faut que je revienne un peu en
arrière et d'autre part je dispose d'un
crédit de temps assez mince donc je vais
être obligé de parler en langage peu
schématique j'espère que vous me le
pardonz nationalisation je rappellerai
que c'est le général de Gaulle qui a
nationalisé en
1945 l'essentiel de ce qui est
aujourd'hui
nationalis société nationale charbonage
électricité gaz Renault assurance banque
banque de
dépôt
je rappellerai que un pays comme le
Portugal a nationalisé les banques et ce
n'est pas un pays
socialiste je dirais également que si
l'on compare l'état des nationalisation
en en Autriche et en Italie avec ce qui
existe en France on aurait des surprises
je voudrais enfin rappeler mais ça nous
lancerait dans une discussion d'école
qui serait un peu compliquée qu'en
France c'est la gauche en effet qui est
nationaliste lorsque c'est nécessaire
pour défendre les intérêts des petites
et moyennes entreprises du marché la
concurrence contre la toute-puissance de
quelques groupes nationaux ou
internationaux mais c'est la droite qui
é tatise nous né tatisons pas la
bureaucratie c'est vous qui l'avez faite
d'ailleurs c'est vous qui gouvernez si
vous vous plaignez aujourd'hui dans vos
homélies de toutes les méfets de
l'administration et la bureaucratie d'où
est-ce que ça vient c'est vous qui
gouvernez donc c'est vous qui êtes
responsable vous vous tapez sur la
poitrine à 3 jours naturellement d'une
élection je comprends pourquoi vous le
faites mais qu'est-ce qui me laisserit
penser que pendant les 7 ans qui
viendrai vous feriez autrement que ce
que vous avez fait pendant les 7 ans
gardons dans ce débat le temps qui
convient garde le temps les
observationsort je vous en prie c'est
contenu de la même façon et j'entends
m'exprimer absolument comme je le veux
et je le ferai dans des termes tout à
fait corrects à votre égard sauf que
lorsqu'il s'agit de parler de notre
débat politique je n'entends pas être
complaisant maintenant vous voulez
parler vous m'avez parlé vous-même de
l'emploi
1700000 chômeurs demandeur d'emplo je
sais bien la distinction sémantique qui
permet d'éviter les mots qui la bouche
mais le chômage il les ressenti comme le
chômage et non pas comme la demande
d'emploi par millions et les millions de
gens qui nous entendent chôur
1700000 on nous en promet ce sont les
experts 2500000 si votre politique
continue pour les années prochaines
d'ici à
1985 c'est une association d'économistes
qui disait que nous aurions 500000
chômeurs de plus dans les années
prochaines et vous savez très bien que
c'est également l'opinion du Grand
patnat français si je j'en juge par les
dernières déclarations du CNPF si cette
politique continue nous aurons au moins
2500000 chômeurs et vous n'avez pas agi
contre cela vous l'avez accepté c'est
même la plie de votre expérience et de
votre septenat non seulement vous avez
considéré au fond que le salaire et le
salarié c'était l'ennemi que l'on pouvit
lutter contre l'inflation à la condition
de tenir le salaire et vous n'yêtes pas
parvenu vous avez eu et l'inflation et
le chaage
mais en plus c'est la tare c'est la
maladie c'est une maladie qui risque
d'être mortelle pour notre société 60 %
des chômeurs sont des
femmes la plupart des chôeurs non
démisés sont des jeunes c'est un mal
immense et on fait des statistiques ici
on pourrait établir des pourcentages
dans la réalité c'est la vie quotidienne
c'est une atteinte dramatique à la
dignité de l'homme et de la femme ce qui
n'osent même pas dire pourquoi on les
rejette ils éprouvent une sorte de honte
d'ailleurs
ils se trompent il ne devrait pas
éprouver cela mais ils ont le sentiment
d'être des exclus et quand on parle de
la démoralisation de la France il faut
comprendre que le chômage est la raison
principale de cette démoralisation voilà
pourquoi je pense monsieurkardestin que
l'axe principal de toute politique doit
aujourd'hui tourner autour de la des
solutions à apporter au chômage et
aucune de vos réponses ne peut nous
satisfaire c'est la reprise comme ça à
distance de tout ce que vous disiez déjà
en 1974 moi j'ai parlé de problème
précis j'ai parlé de la réduction du
temps de travail j'ai parlé des 35
heures hebdomadaires qui devront être
négociés par les partenaires
sociaux progressivement je j'entends
d'abord en débattre avec les partenaires
sociaux dont j'ai dit que je les
rencontrerai aussitôt que je serai élu
président de la République entreprise
par entreprise s'il le faut mais branche
par branche en tout cas je pense qu'il
était plus simple d'adopter la retraite
à 60 ans naturellement facultative et
volontaire comme je le demande depuis si
longtemps plutôt que d'imposer la
préretraite car en réalité comment ça se
passe dans nos villages et dans nos
villes c'est imposé la prèretraite le
patronat fait savoir que si l'on veut
ramasser les miettes il faut partir tout
de suite alors on obtiendra quand même
quelque chose la préretraite est une
imposition c'est une contrainte j'ai
également évoqué une politique de grands
travaux une politique d'aide aux petites
entreprises et moyenne pour le
développement de la main d'œuvre
naturellement il faut aussi soutenir
l'agriculture et le commerce si on veut
pas que leurs enfants leurs filles et
leurs garçons viennent grossir le lot du
chômage bien entendu il faut s'attaquer
s'attaquer à la formation
professionnelle et je ve dire simplement
ce sujet en vous disant que pour ce qui
concerne la formation professionnelle il
y a une loi je crois qu'elle date de
1971 qui permet sur le plan de la
formation continue c'est un élément
important de la formation
professionnelle de d'aller jusqu'à 2 %
de du total des salaires d'une
entreprise sous forme de taxe pour
disposer du moyen de développer la
formation on en est à 1,1 c'està dire
que le gouvernement n'a pas fait
l'effort qu'il fallait pour inviter les
entreprises à respecter la loi j'arrête
là parce que nous avons besoin
naturellement d'échanger les propos et
que le temps passera dans un moment je
vous rappelle en ce moment précis
monsieur mitéran vous n'avez plus que
moins de 3 minutes monsieur jcardesttin
vous avez environ 7 minutes oui alors
Monsieur mitan a parlé avec émotion et
je le comprends j'ai la même que lui du
problème du chômage il en a parlé j'ai
agi il y a plusieurs années que nous
travaillons sur ce problème et nous
avons pris un certain nombre
d'initiative peut-être que Monsieur
mitan n'a pas entendu parler des pactes
nationaux pour l'emploi il en a eu trois
successifs auquels on é associé les
entreprises et les syndicats et qui ont
permis de placer de nombreux jeunes
d'autre part il faut savoir qu'il y a un
grand mouvement sur le marché du travail
en France il faut pas présenter la
situation du chômage comme étant une
situation statique je vous indique que
dans les 12 mois de 1980
2829000 demandes d'emploi ont été
satisfaites
2829000 en 12 mois ce qui prouve la le
grand mouvement qu'il y a en matière de
marché du travail en France alors moi je
vous dis une chose tout à fait simple
mon si vous êtes élu le chômage
augmentera vous faites allusion à des
études de je ne sais qui d'ailleurs des
experts tour des experts pour faire des
pronostics dans un sens ou dans l'autre
on l'a vu jusqu'i compris dans les
sondages électoraux d'ailleurs moi je
vous dis ceci très simplement si vous
êtes élu le chômage augmentera pourquoi
à cause des mesures que vous prendrez
parce que vous avez dit d'abord que vous
prendrez rapidement une mesure
concernant l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du SMIC vous savez quel
est l'état actuel de la situation des
petites et moyennes entreprises elles ne
sont pas en état de supporter des
charges supplémentaires et donc les
petits employeurs les petits patrons au
quel on dira au major votre SMIC de le
chre a changé combi
combien de Smic à combien pense ça reste
à discuter j'ai pendant tout le long de
ma campagne indiqué que si le
gouvernement avait comme c'est la loi
autorité pour dcid du SMIC je ne voulais
pas me passer de la concertation avec
les organisations syndicales ça dans le
projet socialiste il y a un chiffre qui
figure et ce chiffre comme vous le savez
donne une augmentation hors augmentation
des prix qui est de l'ordre de 30 à 33 %
h augmentation des prix ce qui veut dire
pour l'année contenu de l'augmentation
des prix quelque chose de 40 à 43 %
d'augmentation du SM les petites
entreprises auxquelles ceci sera imposé
seront hors d'état de recruter
deuxièmement vous avez dans votre projet
je donne lecture le fait que le comité
d'entreprise disposera dans certains
domaines d'un droit de veto et notamment
les décisions d'embauche et de
licenciement celles concernant
l'organisation du travail le la
formation le plan de formation de
l'entreprise entre en particulier dans
cette catégorie où le comité
d'entreprise aura droit de veto et vous
allez plus loin page page 242 et
243 ce livre m'a été remis gratuitement
par le Parti socialiste on l'IS
gratuitement par É un petit peu abîmé
sans doute on n' pas voulu me le faire
payer il est indiqué page 243 dans les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés où
il y a vous le savez le problème des
seuils qui se pose et où la campagne fa
a fait apparaître combien ce problème
des seuils est important vous dites
les dispositions seront prises pour que
les travailleurs puissent jouir
également des mêmes droits et être
associés de la même façon aux décisions
les concernant donc au lieu de relever
ou de modifier ces seuils vous les
abaissez vous les faites disparaître de
façon à avoir les mêmes dispositions
contraignantes sur la totalité des
entreprises alors je vous indi qu'à
partir du moment où il y aura dans l'air
la nationalisation de tout le système
bancaire les petites entreprises
n'oseront plus investir lorsqu'il y aura
les projets fiscaux dont nous allons
parler tout à l'heure et notamment les
projets fiscaux sur les successions pour
les petites entreprises elles naont plus
investir et bien entendu personne
n'embauchera je ne vois pas quel
entreprise prendra au cours de l'été
1980 la décision d'embaucher et donc
vous verrez arriver la vague des jeunes
sur le marché du travail sans aucune
structure d'accueil pour leur offrir des
emplois nouveaux c'est la vérité et donc
il faut savoir il faut savoir hein qu'il
n'y aura pas une diminution du chômage
qui aura une augmentation du chômage
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas extraordinaire
parce que nous ne sommes pas pas le pays
qui a le pourcentage le plus élevé en
Europe hélas il y a des pays comme par
exemple la Belgique qui ont 10 % de
chômeurs à l'heure actuelle et qui ont
eu les socialistes dans leur
gouvernement jusqu'à la période récente
les mesures que vous proposez conduiront
à ce résultat alors deux questions
Monsieur L première question quelle est
la limite du déf problème nous avons
problème de temps de parole excusez-moi
nous sommes vous êtes à égalité mais
nous approchons la fin du débat sur
l'économie pour passer si vous voulez
après à la politique étrangère donc on
vous donne si vous voulez à chacun 2
minutes de plus ça vous fait excusez-moi
de tenir ces compte d' petit parce que
quel est je croyais oui normalement nous
devrions à chacun vous devriez au bout
de 30 minutes avoir conclu le débat
économique nous consevons qu'il est fort
important nous pouvons donc le prolonger
de deux ou 3 minutes qui seront
consommés sur la suite du débat
excusez-nous de faire ces compes trois
questions simples à Monsieur mitant ça
va me prendre une minute première
question quel est le montant du déficit
budgétaire que vous jugez acceptable
puisque vous prévoyez une grande
augmentation des dépenses deuxièmement
est-ce que vous maintiendrez le franc
dans le système monétaire européen et
comment le ferez-vous à partir du moment
où le déficit budgétaire créera l'alarme
dans le système monétaire et enfin les
35 heur avec quel salaire est-ce que
c'est le salaire de 40 he est-ce que
c'est le salaire de 35 he et je
répondrai à vos questions
Mons il y a beaucoup de choses à faire à
la fois puisqu'il me faut contredire mon
interlocuteur et lui signaler que sur le
plan du chômage la France est en 10e
rang en triste 10e rang toujours sur les
15 plus grands pays industriels ce pas
une réussite je veux également lui dire
que il est vraiment très difficile de
discuter quand on représente deux
politiques différentes car monsieur
jardesttin c'est assez normal d'ailleurs
il me place à l'intérieur de sa
politique il raisonne comme si je devais
exercer ma politique dans le cadre de la
sienne al bien entendu j'échouerai comme
il a
échoué le point de départ de ma
politique économique
elle est
d'une sorte de volonté que vous n'avez
pas eu d'aller vers la croissance non
pas n'importe quelle croissance on va
pas passer comme ça de 0 à 5
malheureusement il fa bien y arriver
chaque point de croissance peut créer
environ disponibilité de 30 milliards 3
points est 90 une centaine de milliards
permettent déjà à l'état de disposer de
42 milliards environ puisque tel est la
masse du prélèvement l'état charge
sociales et fiscales la collectivité
peut disposer d'une somme importante
mais c'est pas tellement une question de
chiffre ou une question de disposition
générale ou bien on adopte une politique
dynamique de croissance on essaie de
reconquérir le marché intérieur on donne
les moyens aussi aux entreprises qui
n'ont pas investi car le profit n'a pas
contribué à l'investissement pas du tout
c'est même une des choses stupéfiantes
dans des erreurs d'analyse du Plan jisc
B
au fond les entreprises elles
n'investissent pas leurs profit elles
cherchent des marchés il faut leur
procurer des marchés et de ce point de
vue rien ne sera négligé vous pvez poser
trois questions Paris que le temps passe
quel est le montant du déficit
budgétaire permettit nous avons une
marge c'est une des rares réussites de
votre gestion Deir mais vous voyez je
les concède très aisément une autre
c'est l'une des rares c'est que vous
allez faciliter ma tâche parce que le
déficit budgétaire par rapport au pays
voisins parmi les plus importants me
laisse une marge suffisante pour
continuer de pouvoir animer l'économie
de mon pays deuxièmement le franc
restera-t-il dans le système ben je
pense que oui j'espère que ça marchera
bien je ferai tout pour cela si vous
tirez naturellement la conclusion de
votre de votre postulat que il y a un
déficit insupportable naturellement on
ne peut plus rester dans le système mais
comme le déficit sera supportable on
restera dans le système enfin est-ce que
les salaires seront
ce seront augmentés ou seront diminués
avec le système des 35 cœur la
négociation commence j'espère qu'elle
aboutira dans des dans des conditions
heureuses il n'est pas question de
diminuer les salaires les 35 heur sont
faits pour les hommes les machines
tourneront davantage il faut qu'elles
travaillent davantage elles ne vont pas
au bout de leur capacité il faudra donc
de nouvelles équipes la production et la
productivité s'en tiendront mieux et
l'investissement reprendra je voudrais
enfin terminer par trois observations et
j'en auraai fini avec cette partie
irement mon programme monsieur
vicardesttin il ne coûtera jamais aussi
cher aux Français que ce que vous leur
avez coûté par le chôage 135 milliards
cette année deuxièmement mon programme
ne coûtera jamais aussi cher que
l'emprunt giscar
1973 à 7 % 6 milliards et demi qui
coûtera en 1988
97 milliards on n pas connu dans
l'histoire financière de la France un
emprunt aussi hasard de àxquiler sur le
lingo d'or c'est une faute inimaginable
de la part de quelqu'un qui s'estimait
compétent dans le domaine des finance
troisièmement mon programme ne coûtera
jamais aussi cher que le vol de
l'épargne populaire réalisé par
l'inflation au cours des 7 ans de votre
présidence monsieur je c vous répondez
quelques mots d'abord la volonté
monsieur vitérant il y avait un problème
important dans cette période c'était
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
j'ai posé la question tout à l'heure
tout ce que vous proposez c'est
d'arrêter notre programme national là où
je l'ai conduis donc la volonté aura été
la mienne l'arrêt sera le vôtre et je
vous indique nous pouvons
malheureusement pas en discuter ce
serait important pour les Français de
savoir que avec notre programme
électronucléaire si nous le complétons
vous voulez l'interrompre nous
assurerons notre indépendance
énergétique absolue pendant 5 ans je
veut dire si nous étions coupés de toute
source d'approvisionnement extérieur
j'ai fait prendre des dispositions
telles que les Français garderont leur
électricité indépendante pendant 5 ans
avec le pétrole et le garde pendant 3
mois voilà la volonté nous retrou le
problème énergétique au début des
questions internationales si vous voulez
alors déficit vous n'avez pas répondu à
ma question vous avez simplement
constaté que nous avions bien gérer les
finances publiques françaises et vous
alliez creuser le déficit je vous en
donne acte j'en é sû pu ensuite vous
avez dit système monétaire européen il
serait pas mal d'y rester ça ne se passe
pas comme ça monsieur mit actuellement
du seul fait de nos incertitudes
politiques nous sommes au plancher et
donc il faut agir nous agissons à
l'heure actuelle nous sommes passés
comme vous le savez pour le de pouvez me
dire les chiffres je connais bien chute
du franc par rapport au marqu entre 1974
et aujourd'hui le chiffre de la journée
de la soirée de grandeur ça c'est
aggravé d'abord je n'aime pas beaucoup
hein je vais vous dire les chiffres mais
je n'aime pas beaucoup cette méthode je
ne suis pas votre élève vous n'êtes pas
le président de la République ici vous
êtes simplement mon contradicteur et et
j'entends bien non pas de cette façonl
je n'accepte pas cette
façonander non non non non pas de cette
façonl ce que je simplement vous dire
c'est que lorsque l'on passe
de 1 franc 87 à 2 francs 35 environ en
l'espace de 7 ans cela n'est pas une
réussite pour le franc pas d'avantage
par rapport au dollars que par rapport
aux marqu alors je suis mê presque
étonné que vous me lanciez dans cette
discussion qui tout d'un coup se greffe
d'une façon un peu inattendue dans notre
conversation alors qu'elle est plutôt la
preuve que le Fran dont on se flatte
beaucoup dans les propos officieles n'a
pas aussi bien réussi qu'on le pense si
le Fran resté au contraire une des
monnaies du monde qui est resté la plus
stable au cours des dernières années et
j'indiquais seulement que dans le
système monétaire européen nous avons
perdu un peu de terrain au cours des
dernières semaines du fait de la du fait
de notre débat politique et que donc si
l'on veut rester dans le système
monétaire européen on ne peut pas dire
on souhaite y rester il faut dire on
agira pour y rester on agira comment on
peut agir soit par les taux d'intérêt
soit par des dispositions concernant les
Chang il faut avoir un dispositif à cet
égal à cet égard coût du chômage il ne
faut pas pas dire au français et au
français parce qu'on ne peut pas leur
faire croire des choses pareilles qu'il
est dans le pouvoir de qui que ce soit
et ni de vous dans votre système de
faire disparaître en quelques mois
l'état la difficulté de l'emploi en
France à l'heure actuelle lorsque vous
débattiez avec Monsieur ronbard il y a
quelques années vous aviez une
discussion et vous vous aviez dit il
faut faudra 5 ans pour faire disparaître
le problème de l'emploi en France vous
aviez dit ça en 1977 nous sommes en 1982
donc de toute façon vous l'auriez même
pas encore fait disparaître donc on ne
peut pas dire que le coûte c'est un coû
que nous avons créé ou imposer en
quelque sorte à l'économie française et
on ne peut pas considérer que vous
disposerez des ressources correspondant
à la réduction rapide des charges du
chômage parce que les charges du chômage
vous me les reprochez mais c'est une
aide apportée au chômeurs et si nous
n'avions pas eu un dispositif de soutien
des revenus des chômeurs nous aurions eu
la dépression des années 30 si nous
avons au contraire évité cette
dépression je vous rappelle que dans
toute cette période nous n'avons jamais
eu de croissance négative en France
jamais et que que nous avons eu une
seule année avec une croissance nulle 75
c'est parce que nous avons maintenu le
revenu des chômeurs au travers d'un
système qui est d'ailleurs un système de
politique contractuelle géré avec les
syndicats et enfin quant à l'emprunt 73
on pas entrer dans une discussion de ce
type je vous indique simplement que
l'État a gagné autant qu'il a perdu dans
cette affaire car comme l'État avait
acheté par mes soins des quantités
importantes d'or dans toute la période
précédente comme nous avions échangé nos
réserves en dollar contre des réserves
en or l'État a gagné tout autant qu'il
verse au titre de l'emprunt il se trouve
seulement que les souscripteurs à cet
emprunt se trouvent placés dans la même
situation que celle de l'État français
en ce qui concerne la gestion de ces
réserves d'or et enfin les derniers
emprunts qui ont été lancés quels qu été
les circonstances actuelles ont été
lancé à des taux d'intérêt positifs le
dernier était vous le savez aux
alentours de 14 % pourquoi c'était
précisément pour faire en sorte que
l'épargne qui a apporté son concours à
l'état ne se voit pas privé de sa
rémunération et donc à cet égard l'État
a tenu compte des obligations qu'il a
vis-à-vis de l'épargne populaire je
crois que les les Français qui nous
regardent ne comprendraient pas que nous
n'évoquions pas le problème de la
fiscalité car tout le monde paye des
impôts et nous pouvons peut-être
consacrer de ou 2 minutes supplémentaire
au problèmes fiscaux vous avez tous les
deux curieusement pris des engagements
dans ce domaine pendant cette campagne
électorale et je dirais les engagements
de même nature comme si un vent venu
d'Amérique vous avez converti l'un et
l'autre à la nécessité de assurer les
français si vous vouliez solliciter leur
suffrage dans ce domaine monsieur
miteran a dit le la pression fiscale
c'est-à-dire le volume des impôts et des
cotisations sociales par rapport au
revenus des Français ne sera pas alourdi
par rapport à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et Monsieur Valérie viscardestin a
déclaré si je l'ai bien entendu
récemment qu'il s'engageait lui à faire
mieux encore à la ramener de 42 %
c'estàd que pour 100 francs de revenu on
pe 42 francs d'impôt et de cotisation
sociale à 40 % c'est que pour 100 francs
de revenu on ne payerait plus que 40
francs d'impôts et de cotisation
sociale personnellement je suis toujours
éberlué de ce type de promesse mais
probablement que vous avez l'un et
l'autre des raisons fortes pour
démontrer que vous pouvez les tenir
est-ce que je peux ajouter deux
questions mais qui sont dans ce domaine
monsieur FR mitteran pour vous le le
point central est un impôt sur le
capital mais faire payer les riches
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et à partir
de quand eston riche monsieur
giscardestin vous avez créé deux impôts
pendant votre septena l'impôt sur les
plus-values et la taxe professionnelle
al l'impôt sur les plus-values tronqué
par le Parlement peut-être mais n'a pas
été appliqué autant que vous l'auriez
souhaité et la taxe professionnelle a
été en quelque sorte la vedette de cette
campagne puisque Jacques Chirac en a
réclamé la suppression et vous-même
maintenant vous en réclamez la réforme
alors peut-on faire des réformes
fiscales en France quand on est Valérie
juscardestin je crois que le temps de
parole c'est à Monsieur c'est à de
parler le premier allez-y choisissez
vous avez de l'avance alors nos
programmes fiscaux sont totalement
différents totalement différents et
c'est normal puisque vous avez une
conception différente de la nôtre en ce
qui concerne l'impôt sur le revenu vous
envisagez de l'alourdir de l'alléger
dans les basses tranches de l'alourdir
dans les tranches moyennes et
supérieures moi je suis partisan de
l'allègement de l'ensemble de notre
système d'impôt sur le revenu pour deux
raisons la première c'est que je crois
qu'il faut élargir les tranches du barem
comme nous l'avons fait cette année et
ensuite j'ai observé c'est un des points
sur lesquels nous n'avons pas agi comme
nous le devions que les classes moyennes
catégorie des employés des cadres
avaient eu une surcharge fiscale au
titre de l'impôt sur le revenu
importante au cours des dernières années
je suis donc favorable à l'élargissement
progressif des tranches moyenne ce qui
est difficile et coûteux et qui donc
doit se faire sur quelques années je
suis contre l'augmentation étanche
moyenne monsieur juscard destin ce sont
des gens qui ont un revenu de quel ordre
de grandeur qui ont un revenu compris
entre
le foyer puis que nous ronnons par foyer
fiscal compris entre 8000 francs et
15000 francs s'il y a deux salaires ou
un gros salaire ou deux salaires moyen
de salaires moyens naturellement on
élargit également les les tranches
proportionnellement mais il y a là
incontestablement un poids trop lourd de
l' deuxièmement je suis contre la
disposition proposée au cours du débat
de l'automne dernier par le Parti
socialiste et qui j'ai là l'amendement
numéro 40 du 16 octobre
1980 majorant les droits de succession à
partir de 500000 francs en ligne directe
500000 francs vous voyez ce que ça veut
dire pour les exploitations agricoles
pour les propriétaires de leur logement
pour les propriétaires de leur fonds de
commerce ou de leur petite entreprise
les droits sont actuellement de 20 %
dans cet amendement qui a été déposé je
l'ai là il passerait à 45 % le problème
à l'heure actuelle au contraire c'est de
préserver le capital de ces petits
producteur si on leur prend la moitié
lorsque ça passe du Père au Fils ou du
mari à la femme il est impossible qu'ils
continuent leur activité je suis donc
contre cette formule il y a dans votre
projet que j'ai sous les yeux la
suppression du ctient familial qui sera
d'abord plafonné puis supprimé je suis
contre la suppression du cocient
familial c'est une des mesures
d'encouragement à la famille qui a été
la plus efficace en France en ce qui
concerne les plus-values j'ai indiqué
que j'étais favorable à un système de
type forfaitaire on a voulu faire une
législation très compliquée je vous
rappelle que le Président de la
République ne participe pas aux
délibérration parlementaire ce système
était sans doute trop perfectionné et
trop compliqué et finalement a fait
apparaître un certain nombre de défauts
donc je suis favorable au retour à un
système de taxation forfaitataire
suivant les types de plusvalu et la taxe
professionnelle et enfin la taxe
professionnelle je vous rappelle que je
n'avais pas proposé comme ministre des
Finances qu'elle a été assez
profondément transformé au cours du
débat parlementaire de 1975 auquel je ne
participais pas et que depuis on s'est
efforcé de la réformer et il y a une
commission parlementaire qui est au
travail qui a d'ailleurs reçu mandat de
l'assemblée de présenter des
propositions pour le prochain budget je
souhaite que ces propositions puissent
venir en discussion et qu'on puisse
réformer ainsi la taxe professionnelle
au fond monsieur JCI desestin pour un
monarque républicain vous avez fort peu
de pouvoir puisque quand vous êtes
président l'assemblé fait des choses qui
vous déplaisent et votre Ministre des
Finances aussi non mais en matière de
fiscalité c'est un fait que le Président
de la République n'intervient pas dans
le débat fiscal parlementaire tout le
monde le sait il peut donner des
indications marquer des préférences mais
il ne participe pas à la discussion au
vote des projets monsieur Méron vous
répondez sur l'impôt sur le capital je
vais répondre encore une fois de façon
trop rapide mais sinon nous n'aurons pas
le temps pour la politique inter je m'cl
nous avons déjà dépassé simplement il
faudra que ceux qui nous écoutent
remplissent mon raisonnement qui va être
très sec je dirais simplement que le
prélèvement fiscal les impôts et social
sécurité sociale est passé de 36 % à 42
% pendant ce septne 36 à 42 %
c'est-à-dire que si tout cela a été
augmenté c'est dans le cadre de la
gestion de Monsieur jiscard Tout ça pour
être clair simplement parce qu'près tout
je comprends qu'il étude des problèmes
deuxièmement si je veux en rester à 42 %
malgré les charges que je prévois c'est
parce que j'entends engager une autre
politique notamment une politique de
croissance et en même temps une nouvelle
répartition et j'arrive à votre question
à l'intérieur de ces 42 % bien entendu
42 % de 3000 milliards sur le ce n'est
pas la même chose que 42 % sur 3500
milliards de produits intérieur brut
d'autre part pour poser les question sur
l'Impôt sur les grandes fortunes
oui à partir de 3 millions de francs 300
millions de centimes compte non tenu
évidemment de l'instrument de travail
c'estàdire que l'instrument de travail
la terre pour l'agriculteur euh dans
l'entreprise ou dans le commerce
l'instrument du travail ne compte pas ne
sont pas décomptés dans ces sommes de 3
millions de francs ou de 300 millions de
centimes et nous considérons que c'est
indispensable pour parvenir à
l'élargissement du barême de l'impôt sur
le revenu dont a parlé monsieur
giscardestin parce que je me demande où
il compense et comment il compense la
perte de recettes pour l'État moi je
pense qu'on ne peut la compenser que si
les très hauts revenus sont frappés
c'est-à-dire les grandes fortunes à
partir de là on pourra permettre
précisément que les cadres dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure soient mis à l'abri
des charges trop lourdes qui pèse sur
eux je voudrais maintenant également en
deux mots préciser monsieurardestin que
il n'est pas exact car j'ai déposé un
programme pendant cette campagne vous
auriez pu en prendre connaissance je
reconnais que vous avez beaucoup de
choses à faire vous aussi mais je tiens
absolument à dire que je tiens au
contraire à supprimer les droits de
succession en ligne directe ou en tr
pourou au bénéfice de charges plus lourd
pour les successions pour des
collatéraux ou des personnes éloignées
deuxièmement que je ne demande pas la
suppression du cootient familial c'est
une erreur je demande son plafonnement
troisièmement je ne demande pas je suis
candidat à la présidence de la
République mon programme a été imprimé
vous pourrez en prendre connaissance
troisièmement que la taxe
professionnelle monsieur Chirac et
monsieuresttin s'en dispute la paternité
ils ont fait un mauvais impôt ils en
sont responsables je n'y puis rien
passons peut-être si vous voulez bien à
la politique étrangère monsieur juscard
destin vous avez un un léger retard sur
votre alors je voudrais commencer en
parlant de l'Europe peut-être faut-il
Michel faire l'articulation avec la
politique énergétique puisque c'est aant
de la politique économique que de la
politique internationale or c'est un
point tout à fait capital monsieur
giscardtin souhaitait interroger
monsieur mitéran qui je pense souhaite
s'expliquer sur ce terrain monsieur
liscardesttin j'ai demandé à Monsieur
mitan pourquoi veut-il interrompre le
programme électronucléaire français
exactement là où je l'ai conduit alors
que je considère que la poursuite de ce
programme électronucléaire est
indispensable pour assurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
et pour nous libérer de la
contrainte humiliante et inquiétante des
producteurs de pétrole sur la France au
point de vue de nos approvisionnements
et de nos prix mais je veux autant que
vous assurer l'indépendance énergétique
de la France c'est une démarche
nationale il n'y a pas un Français qui
conscient et responsable qui ne le
veuillent c'est évident simplement je ne
prends pas le même itinéraire que vous
vous misez sur ce que l'on appelle le
tout nucléaire vous mettez tous les œufs
dans le même panier pas moi moi je pense
qu'il est possible de diversifier
davantage les ressources énergétiques je
pense qu'il est possible de réveiller
plus que vous ne le faites le charbon
notamment avec les techniques modernes
de la carbochimie je pense que l'on peut
plus que vous ne le faites contribuer au
développement des énergies renouvelables
non polluante je pense que l'on peut
faire plus que vous ne le faites des
économies d'énergie dont la commission
énergie du 8e plan disait que c'était
l'axe principal de l'indépendance
énergétique de la France ce qui peut me
permettre je le pense très sérieusement
d'aboutir absolument au même chiffre
c'est-à-dire au mêmes millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole sans précipiter notre
marche en avant vers le tout nucléire je
demande donc à parachever les centrales
nucléaires en construction et avant
d'entreprendre un plan je veux savoir
exactement de quoi il retourne il est
quand même normal que je fasse votre
bilan surtout lorsque je sais vous le
savez sans doute comme moi que les
technologies du nucléaire sont très
changeantes vous savez très bien queon
commence à débattre simplement à
distance d'une génération du problème de
la fusion des atomes d'hydrogène et que
l'on ne s'en tiendra plus d'ici peu de
temps au problème de la fission de
l'uranium isotope 235 c'est-à-dire que
nous sommes dans une charnière au cours
de laquelle il convient de ne pas
exposer la France à une extension et
définie d'un type de technologie
nucléaire qui peut-être dommageable
étant bien entendu que comme il faut
assurer le présent et l'immédiate à
venir faire tourner nos usines assurer
le chauffage et le reste j'entends mener
hardiment de font les quatre types
d'énergie nucléaire économie d'énergie
renouvela et anciennes énergies qui
doivent permettre de diversifier d'une
façon plus heureuse ce que vous
avez-vous simplifié référendum sur le
nucléaire ou pas monsieur lteron pardon
référendum sur le nucléaires ou pas
c'est une proposition en effet que j'ai
faite seulement elle sortit à une grande
difficulté c'est la réforme de la
Constitution comme tous ces référendums
à la Suisse dont vous avez parlé sur
lequel vous avez bien voulu vous ranger
à mon avis il est certain que ce type de
référendum serait très heureux mais
comme la la Constitution s'y oppose
avant qu'on ne soit parvenu à modifier
la réforme de la Constitution vous savez
nous aurons tellement de choses à faire
après le 25 mai que je ne veux pas me
consacrer à des travaux de juristes je
veux entrer dans l'action m'attaquer au
chômage et au reste une dernière
question sur le problème de ma part oui
monsieur min Despin mais avant sur le
point précis du nucléaire et des
décisions juridiques est-ce que vous
donneriez à une commune le droit de veto
contre l'installation d'une centrale
nucléaire sur son territoire le droit de
veton
non jusqu la consultation oui la
consultation existe déjà pas besoin de
lui donner euh je note sur le programme
nucléaire monsieur mitteran que chaque
fois que vous avez une décision à
prendre la décision que vous proposez
c'est simplement de vous contenter
d'arrêter ce qu'on décident les autres
vous l'aviez déjà proposé ça n'est pas
nouveau vous l'aviez proposé en 1977
vous avvez proposé en 1977 vous le
reconnaissez un moratoire sur le
nucléaire tous les Français s'en
souviennent et donc le programme qui
aura été fait de 1977 à
1981 aura été fait sans vous vous l'avez
pas obtenu ou facilité alors maintenant
vous dites j'empoche votre nucléaire si
je comprends bien et je ne décide rien
moi-même et vous présentez si c'est ce
que vous dites vous dites je continuerai
ce que vous avez décidé je ne décide
rien et simplement vous appuyez sur des
évaluations sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autres alors vous avez parlé de la
fusion des atomes d'hydrogène vous savez
très bien que ce n'est pas avant l'an
2020 que cela peut devenir industriel
nous sommes en 1981 n'allons pas
attendre l'an 2020 pour assurer notre
indépendance énergétique moi j'ai fait
c'est un objectif pour 90 et cet
objectif c'est que nous ayons aux
alentours de la moitié de notre
indépendance énergétique toutes les
économies d'énergie nous les faisons
toutes les recherches nouvelles sur la
biomasse le carburant l'énergie solaire
nous les faisons j'ai créé le
commissariat à l'énergie solaire
l'utilisation du charbon monsieur Girot
qui est compétent en la matière a
élaboré un plan d'utilisation
d'inventaire maxima de nos ressources
Charbonnières je l'ai redit l'autre jour
dans le Pas de calis donc nous savons
très bien ce que nous pouvons faire à
partir de nos nos ressources non
nucléaires si nous ne faisons rien de
plus dans le domaine nucléaire nous
n'atteindrons pas notre objectif de
moitié d'indépendance énergétique dans
les années 90 alors au fond pendant
votre SEPA vous verrez arriver les
centrales que j'ai décidé et puis
ensuite il y aura un trou dans
l'approvisionnement de la France parce
qu'on aura pas pris les décisions
suivantes la difficulté ça n'est pas
d'achever les travaux la difficulté
c'est de décider la construction de
centrales nouvelles et je vous disais
tout à l'heure je le dis aux
téléspectateurs parce qu'il faut qu'il
voit l'enjeu quand on est président de
la République on ne peut pas dire je
plus tard et Cera on prend des
décisions j'ai pris la décision avec le
gouvernement bien entendu
d'approvisionner la France en uranium de
telle manière que quoi qu'il arrive dans
le monde à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
avons notre production d'électricité
nucléaire assuré pour les 5 ans
suivantes il peut y avoir une guerre il
peut y avoir une crise au proche- Orient
tout ce qu'on nous avons pendant 5 ans
l'électricité assurée pour les Français
l'électricité ça veut dire l'électricité
domestique mais aussi l'artisanat
l'agriculture et de plus en plus
industrie si nous continuons notre
programme électronucléaire nous aurons
l'électricité nationale la moins chère
d'Europe et nous aurons un avantage de
l'ordre de 30 à 50 % suivant les types
de courant vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
fédérale ça vaut la peine si on veut
s'occuper du développement de l'emploi
et l'activité économique en France
d'avoir le courant
électrique faire l'articulation avec la
politique énergétique puisque c'est
autant de la politique économique que de
la politique internationale or c'est un
point tout à fait capital monsieur
giscardtin souhaitait interroger
monsieur miteran qui je pense souhaite
s'expliquer sur ce terrain monsieur
jiscardestin le PAP j'ai demandé à
Monsieur miteran pourquoi veut-il
interrompre le programme
électronucléaire français exactement là
où je l'ai conduit alors que je
considère que la poursuite de ce
programme électronucléaire est
indispensable pour assurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
et pour nous libérer de la
contrainte humiliante et inquiétante des
producteurs de pétrole sur la France au
point de vue de nos approvisionnements
et de nos prix mais je veux autant que
vous assurer l'indépendance énergétique
de la France c'est une démarche
nationale il n'y a pas un Français qui
conscient et responsable qui ne le
veuille c'est évident simplement je ne
prends pas le même itinéraire que vous
vous misez sur ce que l'on appelle le
tout nucléaire vous mettez tous les ufs
dans le même panier pas moi je pense
qu'il est possible de diversifier
davantage les ressources énergétiques je
pense qu'il est possible de réveiller
plus que vous ne le faites le charbon
notamment avec les moderne de la
carbochimie je pense que l'on peut plus
que vous ne le faites contribuer au
développement des énergies renouvelables
non polluante je pense que l'on peut
faire plus que vous ne le faites des
économies d'énergie dont la commission
énergie du 8e plan disait que c'était
l'axe principal de l'indépendance
énergétique de la France ce qui peut me
permettre je le pense très sérieusement
d'aboutir absolument au même chiffre
c'est-à-dire au mêmes millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole sans précipiter notre
marche en avant vers le tout nucléire je
demande donc à parachever les centrales
nucléaires en construction et avant
d'entreprendre un plan je veux savoir
exactement de quoi il retourne il est
quand même normal que je fasse votre
bilan surtout lorsque je sais vous le
savez sans doute comme moi que les
technologies du nucléaire sont très
changeantes vous savez très bien queon
commence à débattre simplement à
distance d'une génération du problème de
la fusion des atomes d'hydrogène et que
l'on ne s'entiendra plus d'ici peu de
temps au problème de
laffission de l'uranium isotope 235
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans une
charnière au cours de laquelle il
convient de ne pas exposer la France à
une extension a définie d'un type de
technologie nucléaire qui peut-être
dommageable étant bien entendu que comme
il faut assurer le présent et
l'immédiate à venir faire tourner nos
usines assurer le chauffage et le reste
j'entends mener hardiment de front les
quatre types d'énergie nucléaire
économie d'énergie renouvela et
anciennes énergies qui doivent me
permettre de diversifier d'une façon
plus heureuse ce que vous avez-vous
simplifié référendum sur le nucléaire ou
pas monsieur mteron pardon référendum
sur le nucléaire ou pas c'est une
proposition en effet que j'ai faite
seulement elle sort à une grande
difficulté c'est la réforme de la
Constitution comme tous ces référendums
à la Suisse dont vous avez parlé sur
lequel vous avez bien voulu vous ranger
à mon avis il est certain que ce type de
référendum serait très heureux mais
comme la la Constitution s'y oppose
avant qu'on ne soit parvenu à modifier
la réforme de la Constitution vous savez
nous aurons tellement de choses à faire
après le 25 mai que je ne veux pas me
consacrer des travaux de juriste je veux
entrer dans l'action m'attaquer au
chômage et au reste une dernière
question sur le problème de ma part oui
monsieur des mais avant sur le point
précis du nucléaire et des décisions
juridiques est-ce que vous donneriez à
une commune le droit de vet contre
l'install tion d'une centrale nucléaire
sur son territoire le droit de
véonant J la consultation oui la
consultation existe déjà pas de lui
donner je note sur le programme
nucléaire monsieur mitéran que chaque
fois que vous avez une décision à
prendre la décision que vous proposez
c'est simplement de vous contenter
d'arrêter ce qu'ont décidé les autres
vous l'aviez déjà proposé ça n'est pas
nouveau vous l'aviez proposé en 1977
vous avvez proposé en 1977 vous le
reconnaissez un moratoire sur le
nucléaire tous les Français sont souvien
et donc le programme qui aura été fait
de 1977 à
1981 aura été fait sans vous vous l'avez
pas soutenu ou facilité alors maintenant
vous dites j'empoche votre nucléaire si
je comprends bien et je ne décide rien
moi-même et vous présentez si c'est ce
que vous dites vous dites je continuerai
ce que vous avez décidé je ne décide
rien et simplement vous appuyez sur des
évaluations sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autres alors vous avez parlé de la
fusion des atomes d'hydrogène vous savez
très bien que ce n'est pas avant l'an
2020 que cela peut devenir industriel
nous sommes en
1981allons pas attendre l'an 2020 pour
assurer notre indépendance énergétique
moi j'ai fixé un objectif pour 90 et cet
objectif c'est que nous ayons aux
alentours de la moitié de notre
indépendance énergétique toutes les
économies d'énergie nous les faisons
toutes les recherches nouvelles sur la
biomasse le carburant l'énergie solaire
nous les faisons j'ai créé le
commissariat à l'énergie solaire
l'utilisation du charbon monsieur GIR
qui est compétent en la matière a
élaboré un plan utilisation d'inventaire
maxima de nos ressources Charbonnières
je l'ai redit l'autre jour dans le Pas
de calis donc nous savons très bien ce
que nous pouvons faire à partir de nos
ressources non nucléaaires si nous ne
faisons rien de plus dans le domaine
nucléaire nous n'atteindrons pas notre
objectif de moitié d'indépendance
énergétique dans les années 90 alors au
fond pendant votre SEPA vous verrez
arriver les centrales que j'ai décidé et
puis ensuite il y aura un trou dans
l'approvisionnement de la France parce
qu'on aura pas pris les décisions
suivantes la difficulté ça n'est pas
d'achever les travaux la difficulté
c'est de décider la la construction de
centralees nouvelles et je vous disais
tout à l'heure je le dis aux
téléspectateurs par qu'il faut qu'il
voit l'enjeu quand on est président de
la République on ne peut pas dire je
vais plus tard et ca on prend des
décisions j'ai pris la décision avec le
gouvernement bien entendu
d'approvisionner la France en uranium de
telle manière que quoi qu'il arrive dans
le monde à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
avons notre production d'électricité
nucléaire assuré pour les 5 ans
suivantes il peut y avoir une guerre il
peut y avoir une crise au Proche Orient
tout ce qu'on nous avons pendant 5 ans
l'électricité assurée pour les Français
l'électricité ça veut dire l'électricité
domestique mais aussi l'artisanat
l'agriculture et de plus en plus
l'industrie si nous continuons notre
programme électronucléaire nous aurons
l'électricité nationale la moins chère
d'Europe et nous aurons un avantage de
l'ordre de 30 à 50 % suivant les types
de courant vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
fédérale ça vaut la peine si on veut
s'occuper du développement de l'emploi
et l'activité économique en France
d'avoir le courant électrique le moins
cher d'Europe et donc je considère que
c'est un intérêt national que de
poursuivre ce programme et d'ailleurs je
note que si on l'arrête du point de vue
de l'emploi du point de vue du
développement nos activités
industrielles c'est une décision
négative ça n'est pas une décision
positive en raésondant si vous voulez
bien un problème de l'Europe au fond non
je veux dire simplement si vous
permettez madame je je veux dire que je
je n'arrête absolument pas de la façon
que vient de dire monsieur
valercardestin l'indépendance
énergétique de la France j'ai là moi mon
projet et mon projet aboutit en
1990 à ce que 200 130 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole puisse être misise à
notre disposition de telle sorte que
notre indépendance sera en chemin et
c'est la différence avec le projet de
Monsieur J cardestin est extrêmement
mince j'entends simplement diversifier
je ne récuse pas le nucléaire j'entends
le maîtriser c'est tout ce que je veux
dire et je voudrais simplement signaler
que les économies d'énergie peuvent
représenter un moyen formidable qui n'a
pas été suffisamment utilisé par le
pendant le SEP de Monsieur giscardestin
et qui doit me permettre d'aboutir
autant que Monsieur giscardestin à
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
pour favoriser les économies d'énergie
monsieur mideran êtes-vous favorable à
la répercussion intégrale de la hausse
du dollar sur le prix de
l'essence la répercussion du dollar sur
le prix de l'essence a naturellement une
incidence dans notre conversation mais
les économies d'énergie que j'entends
aujourd'hui mener à bien elles seront
par des incitations à l'intérieur même
de l'économie française dans le cadre de
notre politique sans avoir à faire avec
les cours internationaux ce sont des
techniques tout à fait connues qui sont
tout à fait à la mesure de multiples
petites et moyennes entreprises que de
parvenir sur le plan du logement sur le
plan du transport et alors sur le plan
industriel par le développement des
composants électroniques à une très
puissante économie d'énergie qui répond
à la question posée c'est tout ce que je
veux dire parce que le temps par et nous
avons encore beaucoup de choses à dire
alors vous avez été largement l'un et
l'autre favorable à l'élection de
l'assemblée européenne au suffrage
universel aujourd'hui sans doute les
résultats n'ont pas atteint vos
espérances à tous les deux alors
concrètement êtes-vous tous les deux
pour l'entrée du Portugal et de
l'Espagne dans le marché commun
êtes-vous tous les deux pour le maintien
de l'Angleterre dans le marché commun
monsieurusctin très
simplement je suis pour le M tien de
l'Angleterre dans le marché commun dans
selon les dispositions existantes du
traité de Rome je me suis battu depuis
un an pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
modification de ces dispositions ni en
ce qui concerne la pêche ni en ce qui
concerne l'agriculture je n'accepterai
pas des modification de ces dispositions
si elle devait être demandé comme la
condition du maintien de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché commun en
ce qui concerne l'Espagne et le Portugal
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait une
négociation très attentive car leur
situation économique la situation de
certaines de leur production est très
différente de la nôtre et notamment les
productions agricoles méditerranéennes
donc il y a une négociation en cours
cette négociation doit être conduite
avec toute la minutie désirable et elle
doit comporter en particulier une longue
période de transition à l'heure actuelle
les espagnol paraissent demander
eux-même une durée de 10 ans et en même
temps des garanties concernant
l'organisation des marchés des
productions Méditerranées est-ce que
vous nesérriez pas au début que ça irait
plus vite et qu'il n'y aurait pas besoin
de faire de décréter une pause non pas
du tout j'ai toujours distingué deux
choses qui était la position politique
de la France je disais d'un point de vue
politique la France qui est la voisine
et l'amie des pays latins ne va pas
prendre une position négative alors que
tous les autres pays d'Europe sont
favorables mais j'ai indiqué dès le
départ je vous renvoie un discours que
j'ai prononcé à Carpentra à cet égard
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait une
négociation très attentive une longue
période de transition et des garanties
pour nos productions méditerranéennes je
n'ai pas changé la vie monsieur Giscard
destin vous dites le maintien de la
Grande Bretagne dans le marché commun
dépend de telle ou telle condition mais
avez-vous le moindre moyen de faire
sortir la Grande-Bretagne du marché
commun si les Anglais ne veulent pas en
sortir là il faudrait malheureusement
plus de temps je dis simplement vous
avez mal interprété ma pensée j'ai dit
que j'étais favorable à ce que la
Grande-Bretagne reste dans le marché
commun à condition bien entendu qu'elle
accepte le les règles qui régissent le
marché commun c'est-à-dire les règles du
traité de Rome or la Grande-Bretagne ne
peut pas modifier les règles du traité
de Rome si donc elle estimait que ces
règles ne lui convenaient pas c'est elle
qui devrait en tirer des conséquences et
ça n'est pas nous je dis simplement que
nous ne modifierons pas les règles du
trait de Rome pour faciliter ou
maintenir l'adhésion de tel ou tel pays
particulier vous ne craignez pas que la
politique agricole commune européenne où
se décide le sort des paysans français
aujourd'hui car tout cela ne dépend plus
seulement de Paris ne soit bloqué par le
système tel qu'il existe alors
premièrement nous avons obtenu une
décision sur les prix que nous avons
obtenu au prix d'un débat diffic
difficile et où je me suis engagé
personnellement et j'indique à notre
agriculture que Monsieur mitérant
c'était peut-être pour vous faire
plaisir monsieur jusardestin et parce
qu'on est en tenir compte de
l'importance que nous attachons à la
situation de l'agriculture française
européenne faire plaisir ça n'a pas de
sens j'indique aux agriculteurs français
que l'effort pour l'années 1980 c'est de
modérer les coûts de production de façon
à ce que les coûts de production soit
inférieur révolution soit inférieur à ce
qui a été décidé pour les prix c'est
pour les prix on a obtenu 12,2 % et vous
savez que le rythme actuel de hausse des
prix en France a diminué d'environ un
point depuis le début de l'année il est
encore à l'heure actuelle trop fort il
est de l'ordre de 12,5 % environ si nous
poursuivons notre effort nous serons à
la fin de l'année nous devons être
normalement d'après les évaluations à un
rythme qui sera inférieur à
l'augmentation des prises agricoles et
les dispositions seront prises pour que
l'augmentation des coûts de production
en agriculture ne soit pas supérieur à
la hausse des prix que nous avons obtenu
à Bruxelles quant au reste la discussion
sur le marché commun agricole je vous
répète il y a des règles et ce sont ceux
qui demandent des modification de ces
règles qui sont en position de faiblesse
alors qu'on peut toujours faire croire
aux Français que ce sont ceux qui comme
nous
souhaitons simplement le maintien des
règles qui sont en péril nous nous
battrons pour le maintien des règles
existantes du Marché Commun agricole
monsieur mitéron sur l'Europe et bien je
suis
favorable au maintien des 10 pays qui se
trouve actuellement dans l'Europe du
Marché Commun même
si certains de ces pays ne se comporte
pas comme je le
souhaiterais je voudrais simplement que
notre diplomatie surtout face à la
Grande-Bretagne soit plus vigilante elle
ne l'a pas été dans l'affaire des
moutons elle ne l'a pas été dans
l'affaire des pêcheurs elle ne l'a été
qu'insuffisamment dans l'affaire des
prises agricoles deuxièmement pour
l'Espagne et le Portugal j'ai fait
valoir avant 1979 c'estd les élections
européennes ce que je pensais de ce
problème j'ai posé divers préalables
économiqu agrico industriel caractère
régional caractère de la pêche en
Méditerranée à l'entrée de l'Espagne
notamment à l'époque quelqu'un m'a
contredit avec une certaine véhéence
c'était monsieur liscardestin qui
estimait que c'était absurde et avoir le
regard tourné vers le passé que de
refuser l'entrée immédiate de l'Espagne
et du Portugal dans le marché commun je
suis heureux de voir que le bon sens l'a
emporté et que finalement le président
de la République mon cardesttin ses
fonctions qu' exprimé et rejoint mon
point de vue dans cette affaire l'Europe
c'est une affaire de volonté c'est aussi
une affaire d'intérêt S
encore faut-il vouloir faire de l'Europe
une force politique et économique
sociale culturelle qui soit en mesure de
restituer à chacun des pays qui la
composent le rang que la France tient
encore et dont elle a bien besoin pour
face aux superpuissances disposer
d'alliés sûr qui représentons une force
commune dans le monde c'est vrai déjà du
plan commercial cela devrait être vrai
dans T domaines sans quoi l'Europe se
dissociera inévitablement monsieur
mitteran pour gérer l'Europe il faut de
l'argent dans la caisse or il semble que
le budget de la communauté atteigne la
limite des prélèvements autorisés
aujourd'hui sur les ressources de la
communauté êtes-vous favorable à
l'accroissement des ressources propres
de la communauté c'est-à-dire à lever un
impôt supplémentaire qui lui soit
destiné c'est une très grande difficulté
S moi je n'y suis pour rien ce qui est
vrai c'est que il faut que la communauté
reste dans la mesure par rapport au
Parlement nationaux il ne faut pas
qu'elle déborde par rapport au
gouvernement nationaux par rapport au
pays qui la compose il faut pas qu'elle
déborde et pourtant je lui reconnais un
grand rôle notamment dans le domaine des
relations entre l'Europe et le tirmonde
quand on pense que la communauté exporte
40 % de ces marchandis vers le tirmonde
je pense que là on manque une très
grande occasion de développer nos
industries de rallumer notre croissance
par une politique audacieuse
intelligente et généreuse à l'égard du
TIM euh vous me direz simpement ce que
vous nous reprochez en matière de pêche
concernant l'action diplomatique de la
France et vous m'expliquerez pourquoi
Monsieur Vérant le groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée parlementaire européenne a
voté pour une augmentation des prix
agricoles de 7 % alors que nous avons
obtenu 12,2 % lors de la discussion de
Bruxelles on prend cette
discussion sur ce point précis passons à
autre choseche sur la pêche vous avez
échoué par je crois manque de ténacité
dans l'affaire de Maastricht je sais
bien que vous comptez un peu sur le
délai de 82 c'estàdire arriver à
enfermer la Grande-Bretagne dans un
délai de disposition transitoire qui
feront qu'elle sera fort close si j'ose
dire au moment où il voudra fermer à
nouveau continuer de fermer les bancs de
pêche pêcheurs venus de chez nous je
pense que là vous avez manqué de fermeté
ça vous arrive assez souvent monsieur
bérant je vous arrête tout de suite
expliquez-vous vous savez parfaitement
pas du tout expliquezm vous avez manqué
de fermeté ce sont des propos
désobligeants n'est-ce pas quand je vous
demande le taux du dechmark vous estimez
que c'est une offense je vous dit que
j'ai manqué de fermeté pour défendre les
intérêts de la France et ceci fait
partie de la conversation à mastrich
c'était la Grande-Bretagne qui était
demandresse ça n'était pas nous et donc
quand ici il y a eu échec c'est un échec
de la Grande-Bretagne la position de la
France dans laffaire de la pêche c'est
tout à fait simple nous demandons qu'on
s'en tienne aux accords existant et le
pays qui demande une modification de ces
accords c'est la Grande-Bretagne tant
qu'il n'y a pas d'accord la position qui
est maintenue et la position qui défend
les intérêts des pêcheurs français et
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle aucune de
nos zones de pêche n'est effectivement
troublée donc je n'admets pas qu'on
présente un échec de la Grande-Bretagne
en ce qui concerne les demandes
nouvelles concernant des droits de pêche
comme un échec de la France nous passons
peut-être sur point attend en attendant
nos pêcheurs savent très bien à quoi
s'en tenir et c'est eux qui conqu une
question qui vous a été posée sur le
fait que le groupe socialiste au
Parlement européen si j'ai bien compris
oui ce qui ne concerne pas le seul parti
socialiste français probablement avait
voté une demande de 7 et5 %
d'augmentation des f agricoles pris une
position qui m'engage en demandant une
augmentation de 15 % le gouvernement n'a
obtenu que 12,5i % c'est mieux que rien
ce n'était pas suffisant c'est tout ce
que j'ai à dire là-dessus on on en
arrête peut-être avec la pêche si vous
voulez bien et non je crois qu'il faut
qu'il faut aborder les problèmes des
relations estouest vous avez les
questions de défense et les questions de
défense bien entendu euh les relations
vous avez eu directement ou
indirectement une grande controverse à
propos du de la rencontre que Monsieur
Jer desestin a eu à varsevie avec
Monsieur brageneev vous apprécierez s'il
convient que vous reveniez sur cette
querelle mais il y a une question me
semble-t-il que les Français se posent
dans l'hypothèse où l'Union soviétique
serait amené à intervenir à nouveau dans
un pays extérieur à elle-même ce fut le
cas en Afghanistan ce pourrait être
éventuellement le cas en Europe
orientale ou ailleurs quelles sont les
sanctions que vous souhaiteriez voir
prendre pour répliquer à une telle
intervention et la croyez-vous possible
voire
probable
monsieurier j'ai un peu de retard sur
Monsieur J cardestin vous allez
l'accroître si c'est moi qui commence ou
mais concluez vite répondez vite ou j'ai
en effet
condamné le voyage de Monsieur J
cardestin à Varsovie dans les conditions
où ce voyage s'est produit je trouve
tout à fait normal que le Président de
la République rencontre qui il veut si
cela sert les intérêts de la France je
pense que peu de temps après l'invasion
de l'Afghanistan c'était un geste qui
cautionnait un acte contraire au droit
des gens au droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux- même et que tout acte de ce genre
est naturellement dommageable pour la
paix et comme une controverse s'est
engagée à ce sujet je voudrais faire
deux remarques pour bien montrer que
telle était l'intention de monsieur
gicardestin se rend à barsovie que de
faire autre chose que ce qu'il a dit
dans une conférence de presse parlant du
peuple afghan qui se bat pour sa liberté
il a dit les
rebelles et le 1er mai de l'année
suivante en
1980 l'ambassadeur de France était le
seul ambassadeur des pays Occident t à
se trouver au défilé de la Place Rouge
c'est-à-dire que dans cette affaire il
me semble et moi je suis très partisan
naturellement d'un accord avec la Russie
mais dans la fermeté et non pas dans une
certaine forme de soumission au fait
accompis voilà ce que je veux dire vous
savez que j'aiai pas accepté les propos
désobligeants tenus par Monsieur
François mitteran vis-à-vis du président
de la République française lorsqu'il a
commenté de façon sarcastique la
rencontre de Varsovie à la la télévision
je ne rappellerai même pas les termes
que vous avez employés vous ne le
souhaitez pas lorsqu'on doit juger un
acte il faut en connaître le déroulement
je vous rappellerai d'abord ce qu' a été
la déclaration elle mérite la lecture du
Parti socialiste après les événements
d'Afghanistan le 2 janvier 1980 après
qu'il y ait déjà eu les déclarations
publiques des pays occidentaux le Parti
socialiste a dit ceci à la suite de
l'invasion de l'Afghanistan par les
troupes soviétiques le bureau exécutif
du parti socialiste déclare le Parti
socialiste condamne cette intervention
comme il a condamné les interventions
américaines en Asie du Sud et en
Amérique Latine où les interventions du
gouvernement français en Afrique voilà
la position qui a été prise sur
l'Afghanistan si je suis allé à Varsovie
j'y suis allé au printemps je ne suis
pas allé dans les semaines qui ont suivi
l'entrée des troupes soviétiques en
Afghanistan c'est parce que j'ai échangé
dans l'intervalle plusieurs messages
avec le président breenev et que la
lecture de ces messages que je ne peux
pas rendre publ faisait apparaître que
vous connaîtrez le moment venu si vous
accédez à nos archives bien entendu
faisait apparaître qu'il y avait eu de
grandes hésitations dans la direction
soviétique et un débat et même un doute
sur la décision d'intervenir en
Afghanistan et je me suis donc dit il y
a des éléments qui doivent être portés à
la connaissance des plus hautes
autorités soviétiques directement au cas
où des situations similaires viendraient
à se reproduire et ce que je suis allé
dire monsieur bregenev c'est que les
évaluations ou les conséquences qui lui
avaient é était décrite concernant
l'entrée des forces soviétiques en
Afghanistan était inexacte on lui avait
dit sans doute que c'était une opération
qui durerait quelques semaines qu'il n'y
aurait pas de résistance du peuple
afghan et que donc il n'y aurait pas des
conséquences importantes sur les
relations internationales je suis venu
lui dire c'était le contraire et je lui
indiquis également que comme nous le
disons dans notre communiqué
franco-allemand et vous répuier
peut-être la partie française mais le
chanelier Schmith avait signé avec moi
ce document le 5 février 1980 que tout
nouveau manquement à la détente
entraînerait les conséquences les plus
graves dans les relations Est-Ouest et
c'est ma réponse à votre question je
crois que nous ne devons pas agir quand
on est un homme d'État uniquement comme
un prophète qui prévoit les événements
mais comme quelqu'un qui façonne les
événements et concernant les relations
avec l'Union soviétique nous devons
tenter de les maintenir dans toute la
mesure du possible dans le chemin du
règlement pacifique des situations à
partir d'une situation de force et alors
monsieur miterand ne parlez pas de
faiblesse alors que vous n'avez pas voté
un centime de crédit militaire depuis
1958 et que donc toute la force
française s'est faite alors que vous
étiez parlementaire sans un seul vote de
votre part et c'est donc nous qui avons
eu la responsabilité de la puissance et
de la force militaire de la France dans
l'intervalle mais j'avais à dire des
choses importantes à Monsieur brchneev
s'il y avait eu un président des
États-Unis capable de mener à cette
époque un dialogue de haut niveau il eû
été utile qu'il le fasse de son côté je
note qu'on a critiqué ma rencontre avec
varsevi mais qu'on a pas critiqué le
voyage du chancelier Schmidt à Moscou au
mois de juin je serais curieux de savoir
pourquoi et qu'on a pas critiqué non
plus le voyage de Monsieur gencher à
Moscou qui vient de se produire il y a
quelques
semaines vous connaissez cette
déclaration pardon je vous en PR vous
connaissez cette déclaration de Monsieur
shirac le 9 mars 198 nous parlons de ce
problème l'invasion de l'Afghanistan
c'est une honte de cêreu dans cette
circonstance et il parlait de vous donc
je ne suis pas le seul à avoir éprouvé
un sentiment de malaise au moment de
votre visite à Varsovie c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire je voulais vous
poser une double question puisque vous
avez abordé par un BIA la politique
africaine non revenons à la défense ma
question monsieur mitteran président de
la République n'a pas voté un centime de
crédit pour la défense de la France j'ai
vérifié tous les votes non non mais je
allonsir je vais répondre d'un mot à
cette affaire je suis dans l'opposition
et je suis hostile à l'ensemble
dispositions budgétaires qui sont prises
par les gouvernements que je combats et
bien entendu à l'intérieur de ces
dispositions est-ce que Monsieur
lardestin voudrait dire que les
socialistes seraient de mauvais français
qui ne veulent pas défendre leur pays
bon comme il veut pas dire cela c'était
donc une parole inutile non non c'est
pas du tout une parole inutile monsieur
mitéran parce que vous êtes allé
beaucoup plus loin vous avez voté des
textes législatifs pendant cette période
j'ai là sous les yeux la liste des
textes de loi que vous avez voté donc
vous en avez voté lorsque ils étaient
conformes au vu du Parti socialiste
notamment certains projets de loi qui
ont été présentés du temps de mon cap et
lorsqu'il s'est agi de la défense vous
avez au contraire vous n'avez jamais
voté un crédit de défense et vous avez
voté contre toutes les lois de programme
relative à la défense ces lois de
programme étaient présenté en dehors de
la discussion budgétaire et donc on
pouvait très bien imaginer que soit
votre parti soit votre soit vous-même
conscient du très grand enjeu du
problème de la sécurité de la France et
M un vote non partisan sur les lois de
programme militaire je note que vous
n'avez voté aucune des trois lois de
programme militaire vous êtes allé plus
loin d'ailleurs car vous avez accom V
votes d'explication et ces explications
étaient contraires à notre effort de
dissuasion atomique notamment le 24
janvier 1963 à l'Assemblée nationale
quand nous engagions ce grand programme
je voudrais donc parler de la politique
africaine tout à fait bien sûr mais
après c'est une question qui s'adresse à
vous deux après 7 ans Monsieur
giscardestin n'avez-vous pas
l'impression d'avoir en ce qui concerne
votre politique africaine réussie aux Aï
mais échoué au Tchad et au centra-frique
pourquoi et à cause de quoi et vous
monsieur êtes-vous sûr qu'on puisse
négocier en Afrique autrement qu'avec
des hommes dont certains effectivement
sont des dictateurs à nos yeux qui
répond
prierieesire du vous voulez
direintervention militairevention de
sauvetage à l'égard des des Français qui
se trouv
à ce que je je pense c'est que la façon
dont le gouvernement français s'est
comporté à l'égard de président
Mobutu responsable de ce pays qui se'est
trouvait affronté à une grave crise de
caractère séparatiste il faut le dire
avec une large province Raon de
conditions ethniques bien connues des
spécialistes le Shabat que le
comportement du gouvernement français a
indiscutablement provoquer très graves
difficultés avec la population
intéressée de Shabat qui a considéré que
la France se comportait en adversaire et
à partir de là euh cette colère s'est
retournée dans une large part contre nos
compatriotes et le gouvernement a bien
fait à partir de là d'aller d'aller les
sauver seulement ça faisait déjà très
longtemps que l'on était informé des
menaces qui pouvaient peser sur cette
population bref on aurait pu rapatrier
plutôt si on y avait
pensé je parlerai du Centre-Afrique tout
à l'heure si vous voulez pour ce qui
concerne le Centre-Afrique
je pense que je suis interven simplement
de vous demander de presser un tout
petit peu car nous nous approchons de la
limite 50 à laquelle nous devons
interrompre pour que vous puissiez
conclure je suis intervenu en 1972 à
l'Assemblée nationale pour interpeller
comme on dit le gouvernement de l'époque
le ministre le ministre des Affaires
étrangères était monsieur Maurice
Schuman pour faire état de terribles
choses qui se passaient dans ce pays
sous l'autorité de celui qui était à
l'époque le président
bookasa des crimes de toutes sortes 14
parlementaires français de droit de
gauche après moi au cours de ces
dernières années sont intervenus de la
même façon c'estàd ont alerté les
responsables les pouvoirs publics et
c'est ce que je reproche essentiellement
au président de la République et au
gouvernement c'est de ne pas avoir tenu
compte de ces avertissements et d'avoir
continué de
considérer ce régime comme supportable
disons au-delà de ce que que l'on peut
admettre dans les relations d'état à
état même avec des dictatures et je
reconnais que c'est un problème moral
difficile mais il y a un point limite
qui indiscutablement mes yeux a été
dépassé l'Afrique ce n'est pas l'Europe
ce n'est pas la France c'est un
continent très important pour nous c'est
un continent qui a des problèmes
politiques et sociaux qui sont
différents des nôtres et donc il ne faut
pas juger collectivement les situations
dans les différents états africains
comme vous le faisz on peut dire dans
toute distinguer lesting l'Afrique de
l'Ouest la situation a évolué de façon
positive et même nous avons pu renouer
des relations avec des états avec
lesquels nous les avions interrompus je
pense par exemple à la Guinée je pense à
l'heure actuelle au Bénin donc il y a eu
incontestablement un développement de
relations et une consolidation des liens
politiques avec toute cette partie de
l'Afrique au zaï qui n'est pas une
ancienne possession française nous nous
sommes trouvés face à une situation qui
était d'extrême urgence on pouvait
imaginer qu'il se produirait tel ou tel
mouvement zaï mais enfin les autorités
elles-mêmes ne le savaient pas
puisqu'elles ne l'avaient pas prévu les
autorités locales qui n'étaient pas
françaises les entreprises qui sont là
vous le savez sont les entreprises minir
belle je ne l'avais pas prévu non plus
les événements ont commencé un dimanche
et les massacres ont commencé le jeudi
et la question qui s'est posée à moi et
de savoir si je devais prendre les
dispositions nécessaires et prendre la
décision de faire interrompre ce
massacre j'ai donc pris avec le ministre
de la Défense chef d'état-major des
armées la décision de faire partir un
régiment entier de parachutiste et de le
faire sauter à une distance éloigné
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de la
France sur un terrain que nous ne
connaissions pas et nous n'avions aucun
moyen de les récupérer si les choses
tournaient de façon difficile alors
maintenant en effet tout le monde dit il
était bien de le faire personne ne m'a
soutenu j'ai relu encore les
déclarations qui ont été fa dans la
journée du vendredi où j'étais à
l'Élysée 1 minute 30 monsieur jctin
minute 30 il vous reste minute est
encore un autre sujet oui justementz
votre conclusion crique et qu à
Centrafrique effectivement le régime
centreafricain donnit prise à beaucoup
de critiques les événements dont vous
parliez en 1972 je n'étais pas président
de la République la question qui s'est
posée était de savoir si nous pouvions
intervenir plus directement dans les
affaires de la Centrafrique qui était
voisine du Tchad Tchad qui lui-même
était en état de grande crise politique
et militaire comme vous le savez et qui
nous amenait une attitude en effet dont
on peut juger que elle aurait pu être
différente à condition de prendre le
risque d'abandonner la Centrafrique
finalement ce que nous avons pu faire
c'est obtenir le départ du chef d'État
par les Centrafricains eux-mêmes et
l'instauration d'un régime qui vient de
tenir des élections et qui commence à
conduire une vie démocratique dans ce
pays merci une question monsieur
mitteran concernant les problèmes
militaires sur le même sujet je voudrais
quand même faire observer qu'avec
l'affaire du Centre-Afrique l'affaire du
Tchad l'hoire de nos relations avec la
Libye songeer que pendant que l'on
soutenait le gouvernement 1 une fraction
du Tchad que certains de nos soldats
exposés dans leur vie pendant ce temps
on Contin d'armer la Libye il y a eu un
double jeu là qui qui je crois nous a
fait perdre beaucoup d'autorité dans
l'ensemble des pays d'Afrique
aujourd'hui après l'affaire du
centreafrique et l'affaire de la Libye
plus l'affaire du chchad le poids moral
et politique de la France a diminué je
le
regrette sur ce point vous vous trompez
tout à fait le poids politique et moral
de la France est au contraire très élevé
en Afrique j'en ai reçu les témoignages
de la quasi totalité des chefs d'État
africains récemment simplement je n'ai
pas voulu en faire état dans cette
campagne su été déplacé et en ce qui
concerne la Libye vous savez fort bien
que nos livraisons d'armes ont été
interrompu dès le début des événements
d'intervention militaire libien au chat
vous n'avez pas une question vous n'avez
pas vendu on n' pas vendu pas vous
naturellement on n'a pas vendu des
tonnes d'Anger Matra des fusées en
décembre à la Libye à ma connaissance
non nous avonss bien à ma connaissance
non et et un mot monsieur mitéran sur
les problèmes militaires si vous deviez
être en charge de la responsabilité de
président la République seriez-vous
favorable ou non à la construction d'une
bombe à neutron c'est-à-dire cet
armement nucléaire de moyenne porté qui
agit sur des troupes ennemis sans
détruire les territoires dans lesquels
elle est utilisé réponse en une minute
c'est une bombe d'une portée assez
réduite qui s'inscrit dans une autre
stratégie que la stratégie de disasion
nucléaire c'est ce qu'on appelle la
bataille de l'avant elle implique que
des discussions est eu lieu entre les
Alliés et de ce point de vue je pense
que la France sous l'autorité de
monsieurs liscardestin n'était pas prête
à cela il y a donc un problème qui se
pose et je ne suis pas favorable à la
construction de la bombe à neutre c'est
votre avis aussi monsieur non mon avis
est tout à fait différent la France doit
pouvoir disposer de tous les moyens
d'armement modne pour faire face à tous
les types de situations possibles et en
particulier elle ne doit pas prendre de
retard nous n'avons pas décidé la
fabrication mais nous avons pris les
dispositions nécessaires pour que nous
puissions être capable de la fabriquer
si nous le décidions ainsi alors nous
nous rejoignons alors merci vous êtes
tous les deux presque égalité à 10
secondes d'écart et au terme de Monsieur
miteran il vous reste une minute si vous
le voulez par rapport à Monsieur
giscardestin si vous souhaitez sur ce
point précis pour ne pas relancer le
débat et ne pas imposer à Monsieur
giscardestin de vous écouter sans
pouvoir vous répondre dire un mot vous
pouvez le faire nous vous demandons
simplement de le faire de telle sorte
que Monsieur Gess DIN ne soit pas
contraint de vous répondre car lui il ne
lui reste qu'une seule seconde mais je
suis tout prêt à passer une partie de
mon modeste temps à Monsieur jcardtin
pour qu'il me réponde à la question que
je lui pose à propos d'Israël pourquoi
le gouvernement de français a-t-il été à
ce point hostile aux accords de C David
alors que c'était une marche vers la
paix et d'autre part pourquoi est-il
allé en Jordanie pour observer ce qui
était une d'un symbole fâcheux le
territoire israélien d'un fortin de
Jordanie et maintenant je lui donne le
reste de mon temps s'il le souhaite pour
pouvoir me répondre je sais pas c'est
laion deô si les deux intéressés sont
d'accord il vous reste donc monsieur
Giscard desestinel que 40 secondes pour
non on peut pas répondre à une telle
question en 40 secondes ou bien vous me
donnez du temps une minute ou deux je
réponds
pas on vous donnerit volontié tout le
temps vous voulez maisous li avec des
accord je pense que la Commission de
contrôle acceptera le consentement
mutuel des de candidat
al sur la question d'Israël monsieur
mitérant vous avez prononcé une phrase
que je n'ai jamais prononcé j'en ai le
texte sous les yeux c'est l'expression
État palestinien je connais le sens et
la portée des mots dans cette affaire du
Proche Orient je n'ai jamais prononcé le
mot d'État palestinien j'ai parlé
d'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien avec ensuite des
développement politique jamais d'état
vous avez parlé des rapports entre les
deux états État palestinien et État
d'Israël j'ai ici votre déclaration
écrite deuxièmement la photo qui a été
présentée me représentant regardant
Israël avec des jumelles vous savez où
elle a été
priseen suis pas intéressé et bien c'est
intéressant à l'hippodrome de Longchamp
où j'étais au Prix de l'Arc de Triomphe
oui mais est-ce que vous étiez là ben la
photo qui a été montrée photo ou vous je
suis allé en Jordanie tout le monde le
sait je ne suis allé aucunement et j'ai
au contraire demandé à ce qu'il n'y a
aucune présence journalistique car
j'allais visiter les installations
agricole du fleuve du Jourdain à
l'invitation du gouvernement jordanien
et quand j'ai vu qu'il était question
d'installation militaire j'ai dit je
refuse de visiter des installation
militaire la photo qui a été montrée il
faut le savoir est une photo prise à
l'hippodrome de Longchamp je dis pour
les Françis pour qu' soit éclairé sur un
nombre de procédés quant à la question
deand David j'ai reçu récemment
présidentés' écrit à son départ je
reconnais que c'est vous qui aviez
raison raison sur le point suivant c'est
que ce qui est important pour le proche
orient c'est d'arriver une paix globale
il n aura de sécurité pour Israël et
bien entendu n ferons jamais rien qui en
danger la sécurité d'Israël il Nura
sécurité que s'il y a une paix globale
dans le dispositif de David il y avait
des dispositions intéressant vous vous
en souvenez l'autonomie de la S Jordanie
dont j'ai dit qu' que vous n'aboutiriez
jamais à les mettre au CO c'est tout ce
que j'ai dit or il y a un an que ces
dispositions aurent dû être adopté elles
ne le sont pas encore à l'heure actuelle
s'il y a un progrès d'ici la fin de
l'année pour aboutir à la conclusion de
ce processus j'ai indiqué récemment à
mes visiteurs israéliens que nous
accueillerions positivement la
conclusion de telle disposition bien
messieur le temps de débat est donc
terminé il vous reste un temps de
conclusion qui est pour l'un et pour
l'autre de 5
minutes nous aurions aimé je vous le dis
parce que cela ne mort pas sur votre
temps vous posez une question de
caractère général mais peut-être
s'inscrira-t-elle dans votre propre
conclusion c'est pourquoi je l'exprime
nous nous étions demandés à l'AVEC de
cette échéance fondamentale dans la vie
politique française qu'est-ce qu'au fond
chacun d'entre vous proposiez au
français entre les grands projets que
l'on peut imaginer et nous en
avions isolé trois s'agit-il pour la
France aujourd'hui de la mobiliser pour
faire face à des temps difficiles
s'agit-il de lui promettre le bonheur et
le niveau de vie en progression rapide
pour tout le monde ou s'agit-il de lui
demander de faire un effort dans la
grandeur qui peut comporter des
sacrifices vous pouvez ou pas répondre à
ces questions vous avez maintenant le
temps de parole libre chacun minutes en
commençant par Monsieur Valéri gdestin
puisque le sort en a ainsi décidé c'est
une conclusion dont je m'adresse plus à
François mitteran il le comprendra je
m'adresse au téléspectateurs je
souhaitais que ce débat soit utile et je
l'ai conduis d'ailleurs mon
interlocuteur également de telle façon
qu'il soit utile c'est-à-dire que vous
connaissiez mieux la position de l'un et
de l'autre au terme de ce débat vous
avez vu d'abord qu'il y avait le choix
entre deux majorités de type tout à fait
différent une majorité à partir de la
majorit Maé actuelle sans dissolution au
cas où je suis élu président de la
République une dissolution conduisante à
une majorité alternative c'est-à-dire
composé principalement de socialistes et
de communistes dans le cas où Monsieur
mitteran serait élu le deuxième point
qui était important é de savoir dans
quelle direction nous engagions
l'économie et la société française je
crois que les Français aspirent à
davantage de liberté et de
responsabilité je crois que c'est leur
aspiration profonde elle s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé largement au cours de
cette campagne ce qui veut dire moins de
tut moins de bureaucratie moins
d'intervention mon interlocuteur me
disait tout à l'heure la bureaucratie
c'est vous mais il propose de recruter
160000 fonctionnaires supplémentaire
alors que dans mon programme il n'y a
vous le savez aucune création d'emploi
de plus dans la fonction publique et
d'autre part il propose l'extension
massive du secteur nationalisé
c'est-à-dire la perte de la vitalité et
de la responsabilité d'une partie
importante de l'industrie française ce
sont donc deux directions complètement
différentes concernant les mesures
économiques et sociales je crois que
nous sommes engagés dans une direction
où nous devons continuer d'avancer c'est
pourquoi j'ai proposé des mesures
précises concernant l'emploi des jeunes
et je souhaite que l'assemblée dè sa
réunion c'est-à-dire à la moitié du mois
de mai si je suis élu puisse adopter des
mesures favorables précisément à
l'amélioration de l'emploi des jeunes en
ce qui concerne l'économie je vous dis
que l'économie française ne résistera
pas à une injection de dépenses et de
charges nouvelles naturellement c'est
dans une première phase mais il faut
voir que très vite ces charges il faudra
les payer soit vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
parce que nous aurons des importations
massive attirer par notre supplément de
demande intérieure et notre déficit se
creusera soit sur le plan de nos
finances publiques et de nos impôts
parce que notre déficit budgétaire
augmentera mon interlocuteur le
reconnaissait tout à l'heure et que tôt
ou tard il faudra créer des ressources
pour y faire face et je vous dit qu'à
l'heure actuelle dans le monde tel qu'il
est avec les difficultés économiques que
nous avons l'économie française n'est
pas en état de faire face à de telles
surcharges et chacun de vous qui croira
pouvoir vivre mieux vivra en réalité
plus mal j'ai le devoir de le lui dit en
ce qui concerne la politique extérieure
je maintiendrai bien entendu les grands
principes de la politique que vous avez
vu se dérouler pendant 7 ans
c'est-à-dire la sécurité de la France
appuyée sur son important dispositif de
sécurité et en même temps la
participation à la vie internationale
pour combattre comme je l'ai fait et
malgré les critiques pour la cause de la
paix je vrais vous dire en conclusion et
je ne polémiquerai pas avec mon
interlocuteur je ne le souhaite pas il y
a quelque chose qui joue pour lui c'est
le goût du changement des Français et ce
goût existe et dans le passé d'ailleurs
il nous a joué beaucoup de mauvais tours
parce que on croit toujours que ce qui
sera nouveau sera meilleur il arrive
souvent malheureusement dans les temps
difficiles que ce qui est nouveau soit
au contraire pire et plus difficile or
nous avons tenu un débat ensemble en 19
74 peut-être même d'ailleurs dans cette
pièce j'observe en l'écoutant que ce
qu'il dit n'a pas changé naturellement
ça n'est plus le programme commun mais
c'est dans la ligne du programme commun
ce sont les mêmes alliances politiques
alliances politique avec le Parti
communiste et donc finalement ce sont
les mêmes propositions remises
naturellement au goût de l'événement et
de l'actualité et au contraire moi j'ai
changé parce que j'ai eu à supporter le
poids de la conduite les affaires de la
France pendant 7 ans et ceci m'a changé
c'était des temps qui étaient durs et
difficiles il vous reste moins d'une
minute non il me reste oui moins d'une
minute j'ai appris par ce que
j'appellerai la voix dure et en même
temps il m'est arrivé je le sais d'avoir
tort je ne crois pas m'abaisser en le
disant mais je me suis battu pour la
France et pour les Français et je crois
que cette action au lieu de m'éloigner
d'eux en réalité m'a rapprocher d'eux si
bien que l'expérience que j'ai acquise
me permettra mieux qu'auparavant
d'exercer les fonctions de président de
la République au travers de tout ce que
j'ai vu entendu et fait dont je prends
la responsabilité pendant ces 7 ans j'ai
me suis transformé et préparé à exercer
je le crois une présidence qui sera une
présidence de progrès pour la France et
j'indique que ce que je souhaite c'est
mobiliser ses forces en effet pour le
progrès de l'avenir de la France que je
souhaite avec vous porter très loinci
merci Monsieur
Françis j'évoquerai d'abord les
questions que j'aurais aimé traiter ce
soir mais voilà les conditions d'un
débat sont toujours
incertaines j'aurais aimé parler
davantage du
tiersmonde j'aurais aimé parler de
l'Amérique centrale des drames qui se
déroulent actuellement au Nicaragua au
Salvador du rôle de la France force
morale pays d'incitation pour comprendre
que désormais il n'y a plus que des
politique planétaire dans l'intérêt même
de nos
peuples j'aurais aimé parler de problèm
touchant à la vie nationale en
profondeur parler des mutations
technologiques au fond si nous n'avons
pas été en mesure de traiter le chômage
comme il convenait c'est parce que nous
n'avons pas assez prévu les responsables
de la France le phénomène extraordinaire
de la mutation technologique de
l'arrivée comme cela sur le marché du
travail de machines sophistiquées
extraordinairees qui peuvent à tout
moment remplacer la force de l'homme et
remplacer son intelligence et remplacer
sa mémoire et pourtant il faut bien que
les hommes que les femmes trouvent du
travail agissent et c'est un type de
civilisation type de civilisation de
liberté qui n'a pas été entrepris comme
il convenait par le septena par son
président entre
1974 et
1981 j'entends bien naturellement
lorsque je parle du chômage de de la
nécessité de lutter pour l'emploi un
certain nombre d'observations un peu
rondeus mécontente et quelquefois se
voulant professoral et je m'en amuse
parfois un peu qu'on me pardonne cette
expression en pensant que la situation
de Monsieur gardestin c'est un peu il me
permettra de le dire celle d'un
conducteur qui vient de verser sa
voiture dans le fossé et qui viendrait
me demander pour me surveiller de
repasser mon permis de conduire en
vérité il y a une politique du passé
c'est celle qui s'achève maintenant 1981
il y a une autre politique possible
c'est celle que je développe déjà depuis
plusieurs années et notamment au cours
de ces deux derniers mois pendant
lesquels j'ai dit partout comme je le
pouvais ce que j'entendais faire si
j'étais élu président de la République
et ce que j'entends faire surtout c'est
la défense de la liberté je sais bien
qu'on peut débattre après tout il faut
pas toujours accuser les autres de
vouloir attenter à nos libertés mais la
liberté c'est un mot bien abstrait il il
faut le traiter dans sa réalité
quotidienne quelle est la liberté d'un
chôummeur quelle est la liberté de
quelqu'un qui sans être chôumeur
travaille à des cadences
infernales la liberté sera sauvegardée
si nous préservons l'équilibre des
pouvoirs et le président de la
République sous le subtenat de Monsieur
J cardestin a abusé il s'est emparé du
gouvernement de la République il s'est
emparé de en réalité de la vie
parlementaire il a agi sur la justice il
a agi sur l'information par les moyens
audiovisuels la liberté elle tient à la
centralisation des pouvoirs au fait que
l'État cède une large part de son
pouvoir aux régions au départements au
communes aux associations c'est ça qui
nous permettra de lutter utilement
contre la bureaucratie la liberté c'est
la diffusion du savoir c'estd le
développement de l'école la possibilité
pour les les enfants d'acquérir les
chances l'égalité des chances dans la
vie leur intelligence leur caractère de
ne pas être rejeté parce qu'ils ont des
enfants pauvres de famille pauvres ils
doivent avoir autant de chance que les
autres autre la liberté c'est aussi la
conquête des droits sociaux des droits
des droits collectifs des
responsabilités moi je pense à une
société dans lesquel le socialisme
permettra le développement de la
responsabilité de chaque individu à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise dans la cité
de façon à ce que la liberté supérieur
ça s'appelle la responsabilité c'est
comme cela qu'on aura une société plus
harmonieuse où chacun sera plus libre la
liberté c'est encore la défense contre
la certains effets de la science et de
la technique on a parlé du nucléaire on
aurait pu parler de la biologie faut-il
parler de l'informatique et de la menace
qu'elle fa faiser par exemple sur de
nombreuses entreprises de presse de la
de la presse écrite dans la mesure où un
pouvoir central un gouvernement pourrait
se substituer aux informations de la
presse la liberté c'est aussi la
conquête du temps de vivre il faut bien
vivre la vie c'est pas simplement une
annexe du travail il faut organiser le
temps de travail nécessaire c'est
pourquoi l'axe principal de bonne action
c'est la lutte contre le chômage mais
aussi le temps de vivre faire que qu'une
femme on va pas parler des droits de la
femme qu'un enfant
qu'un homme enfin que tous ceux qui
participent à la vie de notre cité
puisse apprendre à mieux vivre et à
vivre autrement enfin il y a un problème
de liberté qui se pose sur le plan
international on en a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est le droit des peuples à
disposer de même pour cela il nous faut
un instrument cet instrument c'est ça
commence par la présidence de la
République Mo minut monsieur
c'est-à-dire par le changement le
changement de président qui entraînera
un changement de politique avec un
changement de majorité le changement
pourquoi faire pour essayer de
rassembler j'ai eu avec moi d'abord les
socialistes je vois la la gauche se
rassemblée aujourd'hui dans un puissant
mouvement populaire je voudrais que cela
aille plus loin et que la France se
sente à l'aise avec elle-même la
grandeur de la France croire en elle la
France est quelque chose de fort qui
doit être respecté je ne condamne pas
tout ce qui a été fait c'est l'histoire
de la France et j'en hériterai mais je
voudrais pousser plus loin peut-être
réforme mais ou corriger et ce qui me
permettra de réformer et de corriger
c'est de parvenir à établir dans un pays
comme la France un peu plus d'égalité
qu'on apprenne à vivre ensemble dans une
société développée et harmonieuse c'est
tout ce que je veux fait merci Monsieur
pour V pour ce débat nous aussi nous
aurions eu bien d'autres questions à
vous poser nous espérons néanmoins que
ce débat aura éclairé les Français sur
vos choix et votre politique mais
désormais les Français sont les seules à
répondre par leur vote au nom de Jean
boissen au revoir et
merci